Hey guys, do you mind if I count down my cold open to you? Ready? Three, two, one. Let's have the one be silent so that we don't hear it on the board. Yeah, yeah. So hang on, hang on, hang on. Wait, wait, let's be, let's be, so you're just going to go three, two, one, welcome to Smartlist or whatever, but you're going to say the one or the one's silent? No, I'm going to say the one's going to be silent. Can you start at five? Just to give me ready Yeah, right news partless episode in five four three two Hey guys, what's going on no welcome to smart list J, why the layers?
嘿，大家，介意我倒数一下开场白吗？准备好？三，二，一。我们让“一”静音，这样导播室就听不到了。对，对。等等，等等，等等。等一下，等一下，所以你只要说三，二，一，欢迎来到Smartless什么的，但是你要说“一”还是“一”静音？不，我要说“一”要静音。你能从五开始吗？就为了让我准备好。对，新闻部分，五，四，三，二。嘿，大家，怎么回事，不，欢迎来到Smartless。杰，为什么要分层？
It's just freezing. Yeah. Is it? Here, yes. It is really cold, but don't you have heat? You can put the heat on a little bit? Yeah. Did you end up going for the heat package at your house? I live with someone who doesn't enjoy the heat package.
就是冷得要命。是吗？这儿是的。真的很冷，但你们没有暖气吗？你可以稍微开一点暖气吗？是啊。你最后在家里装了暖气套餐吗？我跟一个不喜欢暖气套餐的人住在一起。
So, um, How is it nice and warm over there at your place, Shaunie? Yeah, we put the heat on in the morning. You don't sleep with it on. God, no, couldn't sleep with it on. You gotta put the fan on. I sleep with a fan. You just pick a different fan every night? You just go find somebody looking for a big fan to sleep. And, Will, it's pretty cold in New York, is it not?
所以，嗯……肖妮，你那边是暖融融的吗？对，我们早上会开暖气。你不会开着暖气睡觉吧。天哪，不，开着暖气根本睡不着。你得开电风扇。我开着风扇睡觉。你每晚都换一把不同的风扇吗？你只是去找一个想找个大风扇睡觉的人。而且，威利，纽约挺冷的吧，不是吗？
It's been real chilly, but I love it. You're in a t-shirt, though, so you're using the heat over there as well. Well, yeah, the heat's on. It. Well, yeah the heat's on it's it's quite Yeah, it's quite hot but But I also don't you know, I just came from The gym so I'm running a little hot right now. Oh sure sure sure sure sure so you're still in your juices right now Well, I mean I showered and stuff, but you know, you've got that you did your your core. Yeah
一直挺冰冷的，但我喜欢。不过你穿着T恤，所以你那边也开着暖气吧。嗯，对，开着暖气呢。这……嗯，对，开着暖气，挺……对，挺热的，但我也……你知道，我刚从健身房出来，所以我现在有点发热。哦，当然，当然，当然，当然，所以你现在还处于余热中。嗯，我是说我洗过澡什么的，但你知道的，你完成了核心锻炼。是啊。
Yeah, your pat well you get the, you ever get the shower sweats? Where you take a shower and then you're hotter after you get out of the shower. But I do, I've been doing ice cold showers for a couple minutes after. I can't do it, can't do it, it's not fun. So wait, wait, wait, so you walk into a really cold shower? Yeah.
对，你的拍……你懂的，你有没有洗澡后出汗？就是你洗了个澡，然后洗完澡后更热了。不过我有，我洗完后会洗几分钟的冰水澡。我可不行，我可不行，这可不好玩。等等，等等，等等，所以你走进一个非常冷的淋浴间？对。
Or do you get it cold while you're in it? I mix it up. I do both. Today I did just cold. And so I worked out and I did cold. And then I walked home and it's nice when you come out of the gym and you've been cold and it's cold outside. Hold it.
还是说你洗着洗着它变冷了？我换着来。两样我都做。今天我就洗了冷水澡。我健完身，然后洗了冷水澡。接着我走回家，从健身房出来时感觉很好，因为你一直很冷，而且外面也很冷。等等。
You showered at the gym? I did, yeah. Did you wear shower shoes? You know, I was thinking about this today. Shower shoes? I'm gonna answer your question, but I've been thinking about it a little bit because I brought this up earlier, like when we were on vacation over New Year's,
你在健身房洗澡了？对，洗了。你穿浴室拖鞋了吗？你知道，我今天就在想这个。浴室拖鞋？我来回答你的问题，但我一直在想这件事，因为我之前提过，就像我们在新年假期的时候，
and you washed your hands and I was like, did everybody, remember I said, did everybody else die? Did everybody else get a really deep sickness? No. No. And then I thought about your obsession the other day, you were talking about your colon and stuff. And you're- Well and slippers in hotel rooms.
你洗了手，然后我说，大家……还记得我说过吗？其他人都死了吗？其他人都得了很重的病吗？没有。没有。然后我想到了你前几天对自己的痴迷，你一直在谈论你的结肠什么的。你……还有酒店房间里的拖鞋。
Listen to him, he goes, he's going, yeah. Yeah, yeah, my bamboo shoot clean colon. Yeah, and you know, it occurs to me that everything you're doing is kind of in vain. It doesn't matter, there's no difference, your experience is not different. Completely agree. It's total crazy town.
听听他说的，他说，他这就。对，对，我那用竹签清洗的结肠。对，而且你知道，我突然觉得你做的这一切其实都是徒劳的。这没关系，没有什么区别，你的体验并没有什么不同。完全同意。简直是个疯人院。
Yeah, it's crazy town. So, and your obsession with people walking in showers, hotel rooms with no shoes on, all that kind of stuff. I mean, the truth. It's completely unnecessary, but all I know is that I am that percentage more clean But all I know is that I am that percentage more clean than the dirty girdies that are walking around and grabbing a bunch of.
对，是个疯人院。所以，还有你对人们光着脚走进浴室、酒店房间的痴迷，诸如此类的事情。我是说，真的。这完全没必要，但我只知道，比起那些到处走还乱抓东西的脏鬼，我干净的百分比要更高。但我只知道，比起那些到处走还乱抓东西的脏鬼，我干净的百分比要更高。
But I guess what I'm saying is what is it getting you? It's just, no, it's just a, it's sort of a psychosomatic thing. It's just like, I feel like I enjoy eating the bread out of the bread basket, knowing that my utensil, which is my fingers, right? Here's the equivalent. The equivalent is if you had a fork
但我猜我想说的是，这能给你带来什么？这只是一种……不，这只是一种心理躯体方面的反应。这就像，我觉得我吃面包篮里的面包时很享受，因为我知道我的餐具就是我的手指，对吧？这里有个等价的例子。等价的例子是，如果你有一把叉子，
that you were about to eat your yummy little fucking carbo with cheese and sauce and shit all over it, pasta dish, if you dropped that fork on the restaurant floor, rubbed it around on the floor, then picked it up, then scooped your pasta, you'd be like, oh, this feels a little gross going into my mouth. So that's all it is. I get it, I get it.
你正准备吃你那美味的小碳水，上面沾满了奶酪、酱汁和乱七八糟的东西，一盘意大利面，如果你把那把叉子掉在餐馆的地板上，在地板上蹭来蹭去，然后把它捡起来，接着去舀你的意大利面，你会觉得，哦，送进嘴里感觉有点恶心。所以这就是全部的意义。我懂，我懂。
You know what, and it's rubbed off on me because I was just in Chicago this last weekend. And I went, and in the hotel I stayed at, Flex Munch? Chicago. And I brought, Stop screaming. Oh Jesus, we get it, you're from Glen Ellyn, Illinois. And I brought, I brought slippers, Jason,
你知道吗，这影响到我了，因为我上周末刚在芝加哥。我去了，在我住的酒店里……Flex Munch？芝加哥。我带了……别尖叫。哦，天哪，我们知道了，你是从伊利诺伊州格伦埃林来的。我带了，我带了拖鞋，杰森，
because, and I used them in the hotel room, because I did, I took my shoes off and I was like, I'm walking in other people's feet stuff. And then when you climbed into that clean bed and you pushed your feet to the bottom of that tight little cloth envelope at the bottom, you don't have a bunch of dust and grit and grime falling off. Cloth envelope, you have the grossest terminologies. How's your cloth envelope at the bottom, you don't have a bunch of dust and grit and grime falling off.
因为，我在酒店房间里用了它们，因为我确实脱了鞋，然后我想，我正走在别人的脚气上。然后当你爬进那张干净的床，把双脚推向底部那紧绷的小布袋时，你就不会有一堆灰尘、砂砾和污垢掉下来了。布袋，你用的术语真恶心。底部的小布袋怎么样，你不会有一堆灰尘、砂砾和污垢掉下来。
Cloth envelope, you have the grossest terminologies. How's your cloth envelope? When you, here's what I suspect. Here's what I suspect. Tuck your nards into the cloth envelope. Jesus. Your nards. Here's what I suspect.
布袋，你用的术语真恶心。你的小布袋怎么样？当你……我猜是这样的。我猜是这样的。把你的蛋蛋塞进布袋里。天哪。你的蛋蛋。我猜是这样的。
When it's all said and done, when you are on your deathbed and somebody's- In my clean coffin, unused. With slippers on your feet. You bet. The amount of time and energy you've spent thinking and acting on this is valuable time on earth that you've wasted.
当这一切尘埃落定，当你躺在临终的病榻上，有人……在我干净的棺材里，还没用过。脚上穿着拖鞋。你说的没错。你花在思考和纠结这件事上的时间和精力，都是你在地球上浪费的宝贵时间。
Let me tell you something, in my open casket, if you put your dirty fucking hands on my face, when you cry and say goodbye to me for one last time, if those hands aren't clean. Oh, I'm gonna go and walk in a hotel room with bare feet and then I'm gonna get in your coffin with you. Put your clammy foot on my cheek? On my cold dead cheek?
我告诉你，在我开棺瞻仰的时候，如果你把那双脏兮兮的手放到我脸上，当你最后一次哭泣并向我告别时，如果那双手不够干净……哦，我要去酒店房间光着脚走来走去，然后我要钻进你的棺材里陪你。把你湿漉漉的脚放在我的脸颊上？放在我冰冷的死人脸颊上？
My hotel feet. And make your kids watch me do it. Here's the other thing. I fucking, Sean, Sean, years ago we were doing a rest. My hotel feet. Years ago we were doing a rest in development and I had to do this whole thing where, maybe I mentioned it before,
我的酒店脚。还要让你的孩子看着我这么做。还有一件事。我他妈的，肖恩，肖恩，多年前我们在做一档剧目……我的酒店脚。多年前我们在做《发展受阻》，我得做这么一整套动作，也许我之前提过，
I had to put a pill in Jason's mouth and he was so all over me about cleaning my hands before he touched his face. Before I touched it. I think I had a bottle of spray sanitizer in my pocket. I hate you before I touched it. And then they'd be rolling and I'm like, I need to wash my hands.
我得把一颗药丸放进杰森嘴里，他一直在唠叨我，要求我在摸他的脸之前洗手。在我摸他之前。我口袋里好像有一瓶喷雾消毒剂。在我摸他之前我恨死你了。然后他们开始拍摄，我说，我得去洗手。
And then we start and he's like fucking freaking out. Fortunately my character had to be not into it too. So I just used it. I kind of get it though. I kind of get it. Yeah. I know. Talk to the audience a little bit about what's going on, Sean.
接着我们开始了，他就像疯了一样抓狂。幸运的是，我的角色也必须表现得不太情愿。所以我直接用了。不过我有点理解。我有点理解。对。我知道。肖恩，跟观众稍微聊聊发生了什么。
I just blew my nose all this talk made my nose run. It's another thing, you drink milk and you blow your nose. I don't think I've blowed my nose since I was 12. Well what do you do? Wait a second, wait a second. Wait a second, what do you mean? That's such a bonkers statement. Just nork it in the shower and get on with it.
我刚擤了鼻涕，这些废话弄得我流鼻涕了。还有一件事，你喝牛奶然后擤鼻涕。我感觉我从12岁起就没擤过鼻涕了。那你怎么弄？等一下，等一下。等一下，你什么意思？这说法太疯狂了。在淋浴时直接擤出来然后继续过日子呗。
Ew, all day, what if you have to blow your nose in the middle of the day? Nork it! Who's got a runny nose all day, granddad? Wait a second. Wait a second. You have a cloth cleanex in your jacket. I'm going to save all of these and put them in your coffin.
呃，整天，如果你大白天非得擤鼻涕怎么办？擤出来！谁整天流鼻涕啊，老爷子？等一下。等一下。你夹克里有块布手帕。我要把这些全留着，塞进你的棺材里。
Can I just say, and I just want to say this, and I'm going to put it in terms that Sean can understand, hashtag relatable, Jason. You fucking, so you don't blow your nose, you don't walk with your feet. Do you understand how much? And I'm wearing a cashmere robe right now. And you're wearing cashmere robe? Nobody can relate to you.
我能说吗，我只想说这个，而且我要用肖恩能听懂的方式表达，带个标签叫有共鸣，杰森。你他妈的，所以你不擤鼻涕，你不用脚走路。你知道有多少……我身上现在穿着一件羊绒长袍。而你穿着羊绒长袍？没人能跟你产生共鸣。
And my nards are in a hot cloth pocket. Nobody can relate to you at all. Jason, what's your monthly cable bill? Ooh, 250 probably. Probably, you don't know. It kills me, it kills me every time. You don't know. I want to know, Bill. Oh, 250 probably? Probably, you don't know. It kills me, it kills me every time. You don't know. I want to cut the cord.
而且我的蛋蛋在一个热乎乎的布口袋里。根本没人能跟你产生共鸣。杰森，你每月的有线电视费是多少？噢，大概250块吧。大概吧，你不知道。这快把我气死了，每次都这样。你不知道。我想知道，比尔。哦，大概250？大概吧，你不知道。这快把我气死了，每次都这样。你不知道。我想摆脱有线电视。
I hope we have a guest that can talk me through cutting the cord. No, I tell you what we do. We have a tech specialist. We don't have a tech specialist. Although I don't know if, that I don't know. No, we're gonna find out. I know some stuff about him,
我希望我们能请到一个嘉宾，能指导我怎么剪掉有线电视线。不，我告诉你我们怎么做。我们有个技术专家。我们没有技术专家。虽然我不知道，这我可不知道。不，我们会弄明白的。我了解他的一些事情，
and I know some stuff about him that a lot of other people know about him, because people know this guy, because he is a multi-multi Grammy nominated singer. Open your eyes, God damn it. Don't close your eyes when you say that. Multi, I have to, because I'm leaning into it. This guy has been at the top, he's been at number one
而且关于他的一些事，很多其他人也都知道，因为人们都认识这家伙，因为他是一位获得过多次格莱美提名的歌手。睁开你的眼睛，见鬼去吧。说这话的时候别闭上眼睛。多次，我必须这么做，因为我整个人都投入进去了。这家伙一直处于巅峰，他曾登上榜首，
on virtually every Billboard chart, whether it's the all-genre chart, breakout, you know. Jason Momolo. Best country song, no. Best country song performance. He has addressed issues like mental health issues through his music. He's also testified before Congress
几乎在告示牌的每一个榜单上，无论是全流派榜单，突破榜单，你知道的。杰森·莫莫洛。最佳乡村歌曲，没有。最佳乡村歌曲表演。他通过自己的音乐探讨了心理健康等问题。他还曾在国会作证，
to advocate for stricter rules on fentanyl and drugs. He's been such an unbelievable voice of reason in crazy times. Elton John. just an unbelievable talent. And we met him because we introduced him at a concert out on Long Island in our show. You guys, it's nobody other than Jelly Roll. Jelly Roll! Yay!
呼吁对芬太尼和毒品制定更严格的法规。在这个疯狂的时代，他一直是令人难以置信的理智之声。埃尔顿·约翰。简直是不可思议的天才。我们认识他是因为我们在长岛的一场演唱会上为他的演出做过开场介绍。伙计们，他不是别人，正是Jelly Roll。Jelly Roll！耶！
I tell you what, I realize where I fall in the hierarchy of country music with Jay against everybody but me. Kenny Chesney! I'm a dumb dumb. I fall in the hierarchy of country music with Jay against everybody but me Just saw an article Kenny Chessie doing something at the sphere or something like that that just saw that article I don't want to jump back on a train y'all already got off of but I would like to share an experience with shower shoes for a Second. Oh, yeah Didn't even know that it's a great time to it. Yeah. Well, the fun part is, I'm gonna tell you where they exist for a different role. When you are incarcerated. Yep, okay. Which I've had the unfortunate experience of.
我告诉你，我意识到我在乡村音乐界里，杰是站在所有人对立面而只有我支持我，我的地位在哪里。肯尼·切斯尼！我是个大笨蛋。在乡村音乐界里，杰站在所有人对立面而只有我支持我，我和他处于同一地位。刚看到一篇文章说肯尼·切斯尼在球形场馆（The Sphere）做什么事情之类的，刚看到那篇文章。我不想再跳回你们已经下车的这趟列车了，但我还是想花几秒钟分享一下关于浴室拖鞋的经历。哦，对。甚至都不知道，这真是个好时机。对。好吧，有趣的部分是，我要告诉你们它们在另一种情况下存在。当你被关进监狱的时候。是的，好吧。我有过这种不幸的经历。
Well, you're gonna get into that. Yeah, you have to wear shoes in the shower in case somebody tries to do something to you while you're in the shower. Wait, so you can run? No, hang on, hang on. No, no, so you could fight, so you don't slip. You don't wanna slip barefooted, so you wanna put your shoes with a rubber band. So you wanna supply? No, hang on. No, no, so you could fight, so you don't slip. You don't wanna slip barefooted,
好吧，你马上就要讲到这个了。对，你洗澡时必须穿着鞋，以防你在洗澡时有人试图对你做什么。等等，这样你就能跑了？不，等等，等等。不，不，这样你就能打架，这样你就不会滑倒。你可不想光着脚滑倒，所以你想用橡皮筋把鞋固定好。所以你想提供？不，等等。不，不，这样你就能打架，这样你就不会滑倒。你可不想光着脚滑倒，
so you wanna put your shoes with the rubber bands. So you wanna supply a nice firm base to whatever's going on in the shower. Absolutely, like you don't leave your cell if you're incarcerated in a real violent facility unless you have shoes on. They give you flip-flops, but you walk to the shower in your shoes, and then you normally have a friend
所以你想用橡皮筋把鞋固定好。所以你想为浴室里发生的一切提供一个稳固的基础？绝对的，如果你被关在一个真正暴力的监狱里，不穿鞋你根本不会离开单人牢房。他们会给你人字拖，但你穿着鞋走到浴室，然后通常你会让一个朋友
stand outside of the shower to make sure you're double safe But really the only thing Jason's fighting this shower is the urge to put a finger in himself 30 times later and not yeah for the rest of the day by the way you just described the reason why I don't wear shower shoes All right jelly Jelly Roll, welcome to Smartless. It started the way I hoped it would. Now, are you currently in a hotel room? I am. Do you have slippers on?
站在浴室外面确保你双重安全。但实际上杰森在浴室里唯一在对抗的，是30多分钟后想要把手指伸进自己体内的冲动，而且不是……好吧，顺便说一句，你刚刚描述了为什么我不穿浴室拖鞋。好了，Jelly Roll，欢迎来到Smartless。它以我所期望的方式开始了。那么，你现在是在酒店房间里吗？是的。你穿着拖鞋吗？
No, I just, I'm barefoot in here right now. Goodbye, Jelly Roll. No, I'm sorry. It never happens, but I didn't have, it's a long story. I left my slads on the set. Jelly Roll, before we get, now you've just established you're in LA and you're barefoot in the hotel room,
不，我只是……我这会儿光着脚呢。再见，Jelly Roll。不，对不起。这从没发生过，但我没有……说来话长。我把拖鞋忘在片场了。Jelly Roll，在我们开始之前，既然你刚确认了你在洛杉矶而且在酒店房间里光着脚，
and then you alluded to before, we wanna get into about being incarcerated, and just a rough estimate, because obviously you can't know, how long do you think Bateman would last in prison? And minutes is fine, if you just wanna keep it to minutes. So how long? This is where we gotta be honest, right?
然后你之前也提到了，我们要聊聊入狱的经历，就粗略估算一下，因为你显然不可能知道，你觉得贝特曼在监狱里能撑多久？用分钟来算就行，如果你只想用分钟的话。所以能撑多久？这就是我们得诚实的地方，对吧？
I'm an honest guy. Of course, this is gonna hurt. The Jason Bateman that we know right now would survive because he would be extorted. So he would pay for protection, he would be totally fine. Now had pre Jason Bateman be a Jason Bateman, maybe a day or two.
我是个诚实的人。当然，这会很伤人。我们现在认识的这个杰森·贝特曼能活下来，因为他会被敲诈。所以他会花钱买保护，他会完全没事的。现在，如果换成以前的杰森·贝特曼，也许能撑一两天。
Maybe a day or two. Now, do you find that weak, soft folks like me go in and immediately strike a bargain to be a friend with air quotes to somebody real tough, and so then you're protected? That is traditionally how that works out. Yes, sir. I'm willing to trade my virginity for,
也许一两天。现在，你觉得像我这样软弱、娇气的人进去之后，会不会立刻跟某个真正强硬的人达成一笔交易，带引号的“做朋友”，然后你就能得到保护了？传统上事情就是这么发展的。是的，先生。我愿意拿我的童贞去换，
so that I don't get my, you know, my head kicked in. They prefer money. They'd rather have money. Everybody's trying to appeal a case. But you're not walking in there with money, so how do you, how can you pay for security in a prison if you're not walking in there with a wallet? Yeah, it's crazy.
这样我就不会挨……你知道的，脑袋开花了。他们更喜欢钱。他们宁愿要钱。每个人都在试图上诉。但你走进去的时候身上没钱，所以你怎么办？如果你连钱包都没带，怎么在监狱里付保安费呢？对，这太疯狂了。
Well, back in the days when cash was a real thing, you'd just smuggle in cash like they did drugs. But now, as you could imagine, it's like everybody Well, back in the days when cash was a real thing, you just smuggled in cash like they did drugs. But now, as you could imagine, it's like everybody's got cell phones in there, so they're like, Hey, call your people and tell them cash at my people. Hang on, you can have a cell phone in prison? Cell phone in jail? You can't have one. But they do, huh?
好吧，在现金还是真金白银的年代，你就会像运毒一样把现金走私进去。但现在，正如你能想象的那样，就像每个人……好吧，在现金还是真金白银的年代，你就会像运毒一样把现金走私进去。但现在，正如你能想象的那样，就像每个人在里面都有手机一样，所以他们会说：“嘿，打电话给你的人，叫他们把现金送到我的人这儿。”等等，你在监狱里能有手机？看守所里能有手机？你不能有。但他们有，对吧？
That's the catch. Now, they do have tablets. I haven't been locked up in a long time, so I've missed some of this. But they have tablets now from when I go visit jails, they always show me their tablets so they can email and correspond that way. No kidding. But when I was in there, we were smuggling them in. Yeah, but I've always wondered that same thing. Like you hear about like in jail situations where the inmates can have like, you just have like cell phones or they'll smuggle in drugs
这就是关键所在。现在，他们有平板电脑。我好久没被关进去了，所以错过了一些这方面的事。但现在他们有平板电脑了，我去参观监狱时，他们总是把平板电脑给我看，这样他们就可以通过这种方式发邮件和通信。真的吗？但当我在里面的时候，我们是在走私手机。对，但我一直觉得很奇怪。就像你听说的那样，在看守所这种地方，犯人们可以拥有，你就是会有手机，或者他们会走私毒品
or certain foods. It's like, well, isn't anybody watching and like the guards and stuff? Yeah, it's just. The guards are probably part of the process, right? Yeah, that's the big thing right there. Here's the thing that, and I'm just going off this list that I just got,
或某些食物。这就好比，难道没有人看着吗，比如狱警之类的人？对，就是这样。狱警可能也是这个流程的一部分吧？对，这才是最重要的问题所在。事情是这样的，
it just came in the list of stuff that JB would smuggle. Okay. Okay. A cashmere robe, slippers, preferably Uggs, but just lined is fine. Also, almonds, am I saying that right? Can I also have a pair of socks so that the feet don't get too sweaty in the Ugg slippers?
我根据刚刚拿到的一份清单来讲，这刚送来一份JB会走私的东西清单。好吧。好吧。一件羊绒长袍，拖鞋，最好是UGG的，不过有内衬的就行。还有杏仁，我没说错吧？我能再要一双袜子吗，这样在UGG拖鞋里脚就不会出太多汗了？
Socks or feet, berries, crackers, not too many please, because man, they're addictive. The blue ones, the blue ones. And no shiv, no shiv. No shiv. Wait, I do want to, my last question on this is, and J.B., you touched on it, how does that happen? Like you kind of joked, you go in day one,
袜子或脚，浆果，饼干，请别拿太多，因为天哪，它们太让人上瘾了。蓝色的那种，蓝色的那种。没有削尖的牙签（自制武器），没有。没有自制武器。等等，我确实想……我对此的最后一个问题是，JB，你刚才提到了，这到底是怎么发生的？就像你开玩笑说的，你第一天进去，
you strike a bargain. I mean, I walk in there, I'm me, I'm a total pussy, I walk in and they're like, all right, you've got money, so do they reach out to me? How do I know who's the right guy to side with? You know what I mean? First of all, it's a lot of discernment. A lot of the wrong guys are gonna come first.
你达成了一笔交易。我是说，我走进去，我就是我，我就是个十足的软蛋，我走进去然后他们说，好吧，你有钱，所以他们会主动来找我吗？我怎么知道谁才是那个站对队的合适人选？你知道我的意思吗？首先，这需要极强的辨别力。很多错误的人会先找上门。
I've seen a lot of guys pay the wrong guy for protection. Right, how does that happen? They don't knock on the cell door. They wait until everyone's out for recess? Yeah, or they'll come in your cell when the cell doors pop. Right. But it's also not as extortionary as we all make it sound. It's like, it truly depends on what your crime was,
我见过很多人付钱给错误的人寻求保护。对，这怎么发生的？他们又不会敲牢房门。他们要等到所有人都去放风吗？对，或者当牢房门弹开时，他们会走进你的牢房。对。但这也并不像我们大家说的那么具有勒索性质。这就好比，这完全取决于你犯了什么罪，
where you were. There's a lot of mitigating, outside of the jokes at jail, there's a lot of politics of what actually, why you're there. Right. Traditionally, if you keep your mouth shut, you're okay in there. Really? Do you mind if I ask, and we can cut it if you don't want to talk about it, but why you're there. Traditionally, if you keep your mouth shut, you're okay in there.
你在哪里。有很多缓和因素，抛开监狱的笑话不谈，这里面有很多关于你为什么会到那里的政治学。对。传统上，如果你闭紧嘴巴，你在里面就能过得去。真的吗？你介意我问一下吗——如果你不想谈我们可以剪掉——你为什么会在里面。传统上，如果你闭紧嘴巴，你在里面就能过得去。
Do you mind if I ask, and we can cut it if you don't wanna talk about it, but why you were in there? No, no, I appreciate you asking, Sean. I wanna talk about it because I think it's a really important part of my redemption is that whenever I was a younger man, I had committed a series of crimes,
你介意我问一下吗——如果你不想谈我们可以剪掉——你为什么会在里面？不，不，我很感激你问起，肖恩。我想谈谈，因为我认为这是我完成救赎的一个非常重要的部分：每当我年轻的时候，我曾犯下了一系列罪行，
one of which being an armed robbery case, which is the one that ended up really sending me to prison but sadly it's been everything from armed robbery to possession with intent to distribute I've just I was a lot I was a 10 year 12 years in and out of the system kind of kid Caught my first case when I was like 14 years old from 14 to 25 I probably did almost that about almost that most of that decade incarcerated.
其中之一就是持械抢劫案，这最终让我真正进了监狱。但遗憾的是，从持械抢劫到意图贩毒持有，各种罪行都有。我曾经是个……在体制内进进出出了10年、12年的那种孩子。我大约14岁时背上了第一个案子，从14岁到25岁，这大约十年里，我几乎都在监狱里度过。
I call it the revolving doors that once you get in, but I think it's important that I talk about it because it's a big thing. I want to give people hope and second chances and also I never want to act like I'm running from what I did or my victim deserves better than for me to act like it didn't happen. You know what I mean? My victim, did, or my victim deserves better than for me to act like it didn't happen.
我称之为旋转门，一旦你进去了……但我认为谈论这件事很重要，因为这是一件大事。我想给人们带来希望和第二次机会，而且我绝不想表现得像是在逃避我所做的事，我的受害者值得更好的对待，而不是让我装作这一切没有发生过。你知道我的意思吗？我的受害者，曾……或者我的受害者值得更好的对待，而不是让我装作这一切没有发生过。
You know what I mean? My victim, nobody else, my victim deserves better. Yeah, and you know, it's funny you talk about Second Chance. I love your story. You're such a good guy, and truly, and I think that, you know, redemption, not enough of a premium is put on it in today's culture. Certainly, we hold people to a crazy standard
你知道我的意思吗？我的受害者，没有别人，我的受害者值得更好的对待。对，你知道，你谈到第二次机会时很有意思。我喜欢你的故事。你是个这么好的人，真的，而且我认为，你知道，救赎——在当今文化中，没有给它赋予足够的价值。当然，我们用一种疯狂的标准去要求人们：
of one strike and you're out now for a lot less egregious crimes than armed robbery. Somebody might miss, I'm not talking about people who really are saying things to injure people or carrying on in a way that's not, but certainly there are people who fuck up. You're in the public eye, there are people who fuck, who weren't in the public eye, but it becomes public
现在，对于许多远不如持械抢劫那么严重的罪行，实行的是“三振出局”制。有些人可能会犯错——我不是指那些真正说出伤害他人言语或以不当方式行事的人，但当然有些人会搞砸。你身处聚光灯下，有些人搞砸了，他们虽然不在聚光灯下，但这却成了公开的事情，
because they did something at work or whatever. Again, I'm not referring to serious crimes. I'm talking about people who made a mistake that are kind of looked at by society as like, it just doesn't, they don't like it. They disagree with it. And so they say, this person is out. And I think that it's a really dangerous idea because you, somebody like you,
因为他们在工作中做了什么或者其他原因。再说一次，我不是指严重的罪行。我说的是那些犯了错、却被社会视为“就是不行”的人，社会就是不喜欢他们。他们不同意这种行为。于是他们说，这个人出局了。我觉得这是一个非常危险的想法，因为你，像你这样的人，
you're living proof of what can be done when somebody's given a second chance and can bring a lot of good to the world. Do you agree with that? Oh, dude, one, thank you, yeah. I mean, that's what I hope to represent more than anything, right, is that, because I don't think I just stand for criminal second chances.
你就是活生生的证明，证明当一个人获得第二次机会时能够做到什么，并能为世界带来许多美好。你同意这一点吗？哦，老兄，第一，谢谢你，是的。我是说，这正是我最希望代表的东西，对吧？那就是，因为我觉得我不只是代表犯罪分子的第二次机会。
I think I became a voice for all second chances. I'm a guy that proves that it's never too late to change. When I was nominated for the best new artist at the Grammys last year, I was the second oldest artist ever nominated for best new artist in the history of the Grammys. Incredible. So it's not only did I turn my life around,
我觉得我成了所有第二次机会的代言人。我是一个证明“改变永远不会太迟”的人。去年我获得格莱美最佳新人的提名时，我是格莱美历史上获得最佳新人提名年龄第二大的艺术家。太不可思议了。所以不仅是我扭转了自己的人生，
I did it at an age where in our business, in the music business, people would tell me I was crazy for startin'. You know what I mean? If you ain't caught your teeth by it, sometimes in the acting world I've noticed that you have guys who will arc later in their career. But like in the music business,
我是在这样一个年龄做到的：在我们的行业里，在音乐界，人们会认为我开始做这个简直是疯了。你知道我的意思吗？如果你没有在这个行业里崭露头角……有时在演艺界我注意到，有些人会在职业生涯的后期迎来巅峰。但在音乐界，
they say that our best work's done between 22 and 27. Right, right. I didn't even start getting invited to a work show until I was 37, you know what I'm saying? I was 10 years past the music prime. Yeah, it's amazing. You know what I mean? But what was the, because when we all first met you,
他们说我们最好的作品是在22到27岁之间完成的。对，对。我直到37岁才开始受到工作演出的邀请，你知道我的意思吗？我比音乐界的黄金期晚了10年。对，这太棒了。你知道我的意思吗？但当时……因为当我们所有人第一次见到你时，
what I'll call the Jelly Roll Howard Stern event, is when I first met you, and this might sound really corny, but I, you know, you see light in people, you see goodness, you see truth, you see all of those good things that make good people who they are. And the second I met you, you were so kind and outgoing and effusive.
也就是我所说的“Jelly Roll霍华德·斯特恩事件”，那是我第一次见你，这听起来可能有点老土，但我……你知道，你在人们身上看到了光芒，你看到了善良，你看到了真实，你看到了所有那些造就了好人的美好品质。我一见到你，你就那么善良、外向、热情洋溢。
And it's genuine. It's not learned. Yes, totally genuine and I felt it. And first of all, thank you for that because being a gay person in the place that we all met, I was like, I turned to Will and Jason like, these are the places that I would get the shit beat out of me you know, 30 years ago.
而且这完全是真诚的。不是学来的。是的，完全是真诚的，我能感觉到。首先，谢谢你这么说，因为作为一个同性恋者，在我们初次相遇的那个地方，我当时想……我转向威利和杰森说：“这些地方正是我在30年前会被人往死里揍的地方。”
But so. Where, East Hampton? Yeah, no that kind of bar. No, that kind of bar. Yeah. No, that kind of bar, you know, like the crunchy bar. Yeah. You know, but so I met you, you were so kind and so genuine, and so what was the thing
但是呢。在哪儿？东汉普顿？对，不，是那种酒吧。不，是那种酒吧。对。不，就是那种酒吧，你知道的，比如那种嬉皮士酒吧。对。你知道的，但我遇见了你，你是那样的善良和真诚，所以是什么东西
that was your turning point? What was the thing that made you go, you know what, I can't do that stuff anymore, I have to open myself up, I have to be. Be the warm guy I am. Yeah. Well first of all, to testament to what you just said, is that just for the record,
成了你的转折点？是什么让你觉得，你知道吗，我不能再那样做了，我必须敞开心扉，我必须……做回那个温暖的我。对。首先，作为对你刚才那番话的印证，为了记录在案，
we would've kicked somebody's ass for you in there. Yeah, no, thank you. It would've been a totally different experience for you 30 years later with us. Yeah. We'd have, I think the kind of the real, the turning point for me, so to speak,
我们在里面会为了你把某些混蛋的屁股踢开的。对，不，谢谢。30年后，和我们在一起，对你来说会是完全不同的体验。对。我们会……我认为了解到真正的转折点对我来说，可以说是，
or like what I thought really did it all for me. As cliche as it sounds was I had my daughter when I was incarcerated. And I don't know why, I do know why, I used to say I don't know why, but it's obvious. I never, it was the most honest accountability and self-reflection moment of my life. Yeah, that's great.
或者说我认为真正改变了我一切的。虽然听起来很老套，但那就是我在服刑期间有了女儿。我不知道为什么……其实我知道为什么，我以前说过我不知道为什么，但这显而易见。我从未……那是这辈子最诚实的自我审视和反思时刻。对，那太棒了。
You know, I had to really sit down and do an assessment of, I was fixing, I just got the news, a guard knocks on my door to tell me that my daughter was born, he doesn't know her name, he has no information. And I am just sitting there like, realizing I'm worth like, I know this sounds funny, it's jail terms, but in jail you get commissary, you know?
你知道，我不得不坐下来认真评估一下，我当时正在……我刚接到消息，一个看守敲响我的牢房门，告诉我我的女儿出生了，他不知道她的名字，没有任何信息。而我就坐在那里，意识到我的身价大概……我知道这听起来很搞笑，这是监狱里的说法，但在监狱里你有小卖部零花钱，你知道吗？
And I had like maybe 20 Raymond soups, 10 honey buns, a couple of packs of Skittles, you know, and I had like maybe 20 Raymond soups Ten honey buns a couple of packs of skittles like I this is what I had to my name Yeah, I had the one pair of clothes that I was incarcerated in I had zero money. In fact, I was in debt I would restitution to my victim. I owed the courts. You know what I mean? Like I'm in debt I'm worth and I what the biggest thing I'm the most proud of in life is that I run the poker table and have like 30 soups, you know what I mean? Like that was my, and I was like, as a father, I should be proud of my daughter, you know what I mean? Like the thing I'm the most prideful about in my whole life
我当时大概有20包拉面，10个蜂蜜小甜饼，几包彩虹糖，你知道吗……我有大概20包拉面，10个蜂蜜小甜饼，几包彩虹糖，就像……这就是我全部的资产。对，我身上只有进监狱时穿的那一套衣服。我一文不名。事实上，我负债累累。我欠受害者的赔偿金。我欠法院的钱。你知道我的意思吗？我是负债累累，我的身价……而我，我生命中最引以为豪的最大事情，是我能在扑克桌上大杀四方，拥有大概30包拉面，你知道我的意思吗？这就是我的……而且我当时想，作为一个父亲，我应该为我的女儿感到骄傲，你知道我的意思吗？我一生中最引以为豪的事情，
is that I've got myself get to such a low point in life that I'm proud of having ramen noodle soups in prison. You know what I'm saying? I don't know why, Sean, but man, that just covered me, dude. Like, man. I get it, I get it. It's funny. It's funny watching Jason, you must be just thinking
竟然是我把自己落到了如此悲惨的人生谷底，以至于我竟然为能在监狱里拥有方便面而感到骄傲。你知道我在说什么吗？我不知道为什么，肖恩，但这真的击中了我的心，老兄。真的。我懂，我懂。这很有趣。看着杰森真的很好笑，你现在肯定在想
about the sodium from those soups I saw. Exactly, I was like, yeah, it's like the amount of- A thousand milligrams of soup. Oh, it would take a week to burn that off. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. So she's out there and you're in there and you're thinking I gotta get out of here
我看到的那些汤里的钠含量。没错，我当时就想，是的，就像那数量……一千毫克一包的汤。哦，这得花一个星期才能消耗掉。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。所以她出去了，而你还在里面，你在想：“我得离开这儿，当我离开这儿的时候，我得离这儿远远的。”所以这就是开始掐灭……不是犯罪的本能，而只是……我不再让那种事成为我生活一部分的原因。对，这就好像有什么东西“咔哒”一声对上了，对吧？对。
and when I do get out of here, I gotta stay out of here. And so that was what started to turn off the, not the instinct to commit crime, but just like the, I'm just gonna not have that be a part of what I do anymore. Yeah, so it's like something clicks, right? Yeah. Because I'll bet you, you didn't learn to be some great, nice, warm, loving human being in jail.
因为我敢打赌，你在监狱里并没有学会成为一个伟大、善良、温暖、充满爱心的人。你一直都是这样的人。我猜想，你的犯罪模式可能只是反映了你当时跟什么样的人混在一起，你认识的人在做同样的事，而你碰巧被抓了，然后就走上了这条路。是这样吗？对，很大程度上也是出于经济驱动。
You always were that. I would assume that the crime pattern was probably just a reflection of kind of who you were hanging out with and that people you knew were doing the same thing and you happened to get caught and down this path you went. Yes? Yeah, and a lot of it too was financially driven.
就像我当时住的地方，唯一有钱的人都在犯罪。在我的街区，这是一件界限非常分明的事。你要么吸毒，要么贩毒。对，没错。而且就算你又贩毒又吸毒，你也比那些只吸毒的人过得好。你知道吗？对，对，对。
Like where I lived at at the time, the only people that had money did crime. In my neighborhood, it was a real clear cut thing. You either did drugs or you sold drugs. Yeah, right. And even if you sold and did drugs, you were better off than the people that just did drugs. You know? Right, right, right.
我知道这听起来很奇怪，而且我并不是想扯出一大堆童年往事，但我母亲有她自己的挣扎，从毒瘾到心理健康问题。我父亲有酗酒问题。我生活在一个似乎把这视为常态的家庭里。对。
And I know that sounds weird, but, and I'm not trying to get into like a bunch of childhood stuff here, but my mother struggled with her own things from addictive stuff to mental health stuff. My father had alcohol things. I was in a house where it seemed very common. Right.
你并没有在做什么奇怪的事。对，对我来说，这就是正在发生的事。对，就像这就是现实。直到后来的人生中，匿名戒酒会（AA）有一句名言说：“当保持现状的痛苦大于改变所需的痛苦时，改变就会发生。”对。
You weren't doing something weird. Yeah, to me, this was what was happening. Yeah, like this was what was going on. It wasn't until later in life, and there's a famous quote in Alcoholics Anonymous that says, "'Change happens when the pain to remain the same is greater than the pain it takes to change. Yeah.
而那……很有意思。这很酷，对吧？监狱里的那一天，我觉得，无论这种改变有多痛苦，我都一定要做出改变。老兄，真的是……当我回想起去监狱进行演讲时，我第一次再去监狱演讲，
And that, yeah. That's interesting. That's cool, right? And that day in jail, I was like, I don't care how painful this change is, I'm gonna make this change. And man, it was, when I go back and speak at jails, the first time I went and spoke at a jail again,
我永远不会忘记，当时我正要离开，听到一个家伙对另一个家伙低声说：“我们所要做的就是变得有钱有名，然后我们所有的烦恼就都解决了。”所以下次再去演讲时，我忘了……我从没有讲过这个故事中最重要的一部分，那就是从出狱回家、决定做出改变，
I'll never forget I was leaving and I heard one guy whisper to another guy, he's like, all we gotta do is be rich and famous and all our problems are solved. So the next time I went and spoke, I forgot about, I never tell the most important part of the story was that the moment from coming home to jail and deciding I was gonna make the change
到看到改变的成果，这是一个长达十年的过程。对。对吧？你知道我的意思吗？我花了10年时间才从那个改变中结出果实。我一直在吃屎三明治，你知道我的意思吗？我花了10年时间才从那个改变中结出果实。我一直在吃屎三明治，你知道我的意思吗？我只是在寻找出路，住在货车里，做着50美元一场的演出，就像……
to seeing the fruits of the change was like a decade long process. Yeah. Right. You know what I mean? Like I didn't bear fruit from that change for 10 years. I was eating shit sandwiches, You know what I mean? I didn't bear fruit from that change for 10 years. I was eating shit sandwiches, you know what I mean? And just trying to find my way and living in a van and doing $50 shows and just like,
我甘愿牺牲。对，这是每天都在进行的。你是什麽时候发现自己会唱歌的？你是在监狱里开始做这些的，还是之前就会一点？我在监狱里更多的是说唱。我就是这样在嘻哈界崭露头角的。那更多是那个街区的语言。
I was willing to sacrifice. Yeah, it's daily. When did you find singing? Did you start doing some of that in jail or were you doing some of that beforehand? I was rapping more in jail. That's how I kinda came up in hip hop. It was more of the language of the neighborhood.
但我总是唱副歌。所以像周五晚上，我们会去牢房里，在墙上敲敲打打——我不知道这声音有多大，但大概就像我这样敲桌子。我每个星期五都会去，在那扇窗户上敲击。我会敲上大约两个小节。
But I would always sing the chorus. So like Friday nights we'd go down in the jail cell and we'd beat on the walls, and I don't know how loud this'd be, but like kinda how I'm beating on the table. And I would go every Friday and I would tap on that window. And I would tap on it for like two measures.
在我落下第一个低音拍子之前——你知道那种节拍吗？等我把这两个小节敲完的时候，
And before I dropped the first down bass note, you know the beat? And by the I would tap on it for like two measures, and before I dropped the first down bass note, you know the beat? And by the time I got through tapping for those two measures, the entire unit, 230 inmates, come downstairs. Jelly's finna rap, Jelly's finna rap. Wow. And I would always, yeah, I was crazy, right? And I would sing the chorus, and it was like,
整个牢区的230名犯人都会跑到楼下来。“Jelly要说唱了，Jelly要说唱了。”哇。而我总是……对，我很疯狂，对吧？我会唱副歌，那种感觉就像……
there would be like, we'd be free. Like it felt like we were free for the night. You know what I mean? Like everybody's standing on tables. Ah, and then I'd write these like choruses like, I'll be gone for a little while, but I can't wait to see your sexy smile. But I wasn't really singing,
我们会自由了。感觉就像我们那一晚自由了一样。你知道我的意思吗？每个人都站在桌子上。啊，然后我会写出这样的副歌：“我将离开一会儿，但我迫不及待想看到你性感的微笑。”但我其实不是在唱歌，
I was just like doing it like that. But they would love it. They'd be like, sing the gone for a little while song. You know what I'm saying? Because it's like our theme. Amazing, that's amazing. That's when I didn't realize I had the voice. Yeah, it was so cool watching music move them people
我只是那样哼唱。但他们会非常喜欢。他们会说：“唱那个‘离开一会儿’的歌。”你知道我在说什么吗？因为这就成了我们的主题曲。太棒了，太棒了。那就是我意识到自己拥有歌喉的时候。是的，看着音乐那样触动他们，真的很酷。
like that. Did you have an opportunity to meet, when you first started going and speaking in jails and reaching out to guys and helping people who you must have identified, were going through the same things that you did. And I know that that's something that, you know, I can relate to that when you meet somebody
当你第一次开始去监狱演讲、向那些人伸出援手、去帮助那些你肯定能认出他们正在经历着与你相同经历的人时，你有没有机会遇到……我知道这是一种……我可以产生共鸣，当你遇到一个
who's gone through stuff that you went through and you can go, hey man, and did you then have an opportunity over the years to have guys come up to you and say, hey, I met you years ago. Hey, you changed, like you coming in here and speaking at this jail had an impact on my life and here's how. Have you had those moments?
经历过你所经历的事情的人，你可以说：“嘿，老兄……”后来几年里，你有没有机会遇到一些人向你走来说：“嘿，我几年前见过你。嘿，你改变了——你来这里在监狱里做演讲对我的生活产生了影响，这就是影响。”你有过这样的时刻吗？
I bet you have. I've had quite a few of them already, especially rehabs, so my rule is, I'm a man of faith and my rule is real simple. My faith, what I believe of my faith would require from me and the person that I follow is that I go speak at jails, I go feed the homeless, I go hang out with the widows, and I go to the rehabs.
我打赌你肯定有过。我已经有过不少这样的经历了，特别是在戒毒所。所以我的原则是，我是个有信仰的人，我的原则非常简单。我的信仰——我的信仰所要求我的，以及我所追随的那个人要求我的，就是去监狱演讲，去给无家可归者送饭，去陪伴寡妇，以及去戒毒所。
Because that's where I think that the God I serve would want me to go, that's where the representation of him went, you know what I'm saying? So it's like. Yeah, of course. So I get it a lot, especially out of the rehabs. The jails too, the jails are so different though, because some of them guys I'm singing in front of
因为我认为我所侍奉的神希望我去那里，那是他的化身去过的地方，你知道我在说什么吗？所以就像是……对，当然。所以这种经历我经常遇到，尤其是在戒毒所。监狱里也有，不过监狱的情况很不一样，因为我在我面前唱歌的那些人里，
won't come home for another 10 or 20 years. But I will tell you a cool story. I went to the Oregon State Penitentiary to do the first, I brought the first music to the yard at the OSP, the original penitentiary in Oregon, the only death row left in Oregon, or was the only death row left. And we took the music back to the yard
有的人还要再过10到20年才能回家。但我可以给你讲个很酷的故事。我去了俄勒冈州立监狱，把第一场音乐带到了俄州监狱的放风场里，那是俄勒冈州最初的监狱，也是俄勒冈州仅存的死囚牢房所在地，或者说曾经是唯一的死囚牢房。我们把音乐带回了放风场，
and there was a guy who'd been in there for 19 years. And he tells my manager, man, he's like, man, I'm coming home at the end of this year. I come home the day after Christmas. I've been gone for 20 years, you know, whatever. I'm just looking forward to hanging out with my daughter. She's 22, I've been gone since she was two. So we fly him out in his daughter
那里有个家伙已经在里面呆了19年了。他跟我经纪人说，老兄，他说：“老兄，我今年年底就要回家了。我圣诞节后一天回家。我离开20年了，你知道，随便吧。我只是很期待能和女儿一起生活。她22岁了，我离开时她才两岁。”所以我们用飞机把她和她女儿接了过来，
for my New Year's Eve show. So imagine being incarcerated for 20 years. You come straight out. We put you in a first class flight with your little girl, who's not a little girl anymore. She's 22. And they came down and partied with us in Nashville all of New Year's Eve. That's amazing.
来看我的跨年演唱会。所以想象一下被关押20年。你直接重获自由。我们让你坐上头等舱，和你的小女儿一起飞过来——她已经不再是个小女孩了，她22岁了。他们下来，在纳什维尔和我们一起狂欢了一整个跨年夜。太棒了。
You know, and I just, I'm thinking about how over, I'm overwhelmed by this, right? And I've been doing this a few years. I just imagine what this guy's feeling, you know? And great, went straight home and got a job and just the character of a man whose vision and dream in jail was to go do an activity with his daughter. He's like, man, I've missed 20 years of my little girl's life.
你知道的，我只是，我一直在想，我对此感到多么不知所措，对吧？而且我已经做了好几年了。我只是想象这个人会有什么感受，你知道吗？太棒了，他直接回家找了份工作，一个在监狱里的愿景和梦想就是和女儿一起做一件事的男人的品质。他说，天啊，我错过了我小女儿生命中的20年。
The first thing I wanna do is go home and be a part of her life. That's so amazing. How soon after your daughter was born did you get out? I got home when she was almost two. Yeah. And this story is even probably the coolest part of this whole story, Jay.
我最想做的事就是回家，成为她生活的一部分。这太棒了。你女儿出生后多久你才出来？她快两岁时我回家的。是的。这个故事甚至可能是整个故事中最酷的部分，杰伊。
My daughter, her mother at the time, because I was rightfully so a fucking criminal, wouldn't let me see her. So I had to go to court, I had to get supervised visits through the courtroom. Like I had to step that very slow, build a relationship, then six hours on Friday evening, but she had to be home before 10 p.m.
我女儿，当时她的孩子他妈，因为我理所当然地是个混蛋罪犯，不让我见她。所以我不得不去法院，必须通过法庭安排获得监督探视。就像我必须迈出非常缓慢的一步，建立关系，然后是周五晚上六个小时，但她必须在晚上10点之前回家。
And then I just had to keep going to the court every six months and going, look, I'm continuing to prove I'm changing, I'm in college. Look, I'm doing this. I'm like, music, being famous, wasn't even a thought then. I just wanted to be a good dad. I just came home. I just wanted to be a good dad. I just came home.
然后我不得不每六个月继续去一次法院，说，看，我一直在证明我在改变，我在上大学。看，我在做这个。我想，音乐，出名，当时甚至都不在我的考虑范围内。我只是想成为一个好爸爸。我刚回家。我只想成为一个好爸爸。我刚回家。
I just wanted to focus on just being the best father. You're working on those 10 years. Yeah, you know what I'm saying? I was just building that. Fast forward, that same little girl that was born when I was incarcerated is fixing to turn 17 years old. She's got one of the highest GPAs at her high school.
我只想专注于做最好的父亲。你在努力度过那10年。是的，你知道我在说什么吗？我只是在建立那个。快进，那个在我入狱时出生的可爱小女孩正准备满17岁。她是她高中GPA最高的人之一。
She's a dual enrollment kid and is junior going to college. Me and my wife have had full custody of her for eight years. This is one of her best friends. You know what I'm saying? It just is. Oh, what a great story. Wait, so she's been living with you for the last eight years? Yep.
她是个双学籍孩子，大三就要上大学了。我和我妻子拥有她八年的完全抚养权。这是她最好的朋友之一。你知道我在说什么吗？它就是。哦，多么棒的故事。等等，所以她过去八年一直跟你住在一起？是的。
Oh, that's great. It's awesome, dude. How cool. It's such a great story of how anything is possible. It's so great, man. Again, that part of your, well, all of your story, I find so inspirational. I mentioned before too, when you went
哦，那太棒了。太棒了，老兄。多酷啊。这是一个关于一切皆有可能的如此棒的故事。太棒了，老兄。再次声明，你的那部分，或者说你所有的故事，我都觉得非常鼓舞人心。我之前也提到过，当你去
and testified before Congress, and it was about a year ago, wasn't it? It was like January of last year. And really advocated for limiting or getting rid of, or what was it, fentanyl and all that stuff. And I remember you were like, I used to be part of the problem. I was a drug dealer and now I want to be part of the problem. I was a drug dealer and now I wanna be part of the solution.
在国会作证，大约是一年前吧？就像去年一月份。并真正倡导限制或消除，或者是什么，芬太尼和所有这些东西。我记得你说过，我曾经是问题的一部分。我曾是个毒贩，现在我想成为问题的一部分。我曾是个毒贩，现在我想成为解决问题的一部分。
Didn't you say something like that? That's exactly what I said, Will. Thank you, sir. And were you trying to help them out on what might be some more efficient ways for them to exact some change? Yeah, yeah, we're working on, there's a, it's a double-sided sword.
你不是说过类似的话吗？我就是这么说的，威尔。谢谢你，先生。你是想帮他们找出一些更有效的方法来实施某些变革吗？对，对，我们正在努力，这是一把双刃剑。
We were working on a bill to stop the flow and the demand, so it's trying to figure out the balance. But it was breaking my heart that the statistic I gave, Jason was, and I don't know if you know this either, Sean, this will blow y'all's mind if you don't, but over 160-something people in America die every single day of fentanyl overdoses. How many?
我们正在起草一项法案来阻止流量和需求，所以它试图找出平衡点。但我给出的统计数据让我心碎，杰森，我不知道你是否也知道这一点，肖恩，如果你不知道的话，这会让你们大吃一惊，但在美国，每天有160多人死于芬太尼过量。多少？
160. 160-something. To give y'all the reference I used in America die every single day to fentanyl overdoses. How many, how many? 160 something. To give y'all the reference I used that the fentanyl hearing is, that is a 737 plane crashing full of human souls every single day. Wow. Now if it was a plane that was crashing every single day, I don't predict this happens for four days
160。160多。为了给你们一个参考，我在芬太尼听证会上用过，每天都有一架满载人类灵魂的737飞机坠毁，死于芬太尼过量。多少，多少？160多。为了给你们一个参考，我在芬太尼听证会上用过，每天都有一架满载人类灵魂的737飞机坠毁，死于芬太尼过量。多少，多少？160多。为了给你们一个参考，我在芬太尼听证会上用过，那就像一架737飞机每天都载满人类灵魂坠毁。哇。现在，如果有一架飞机每天都坠毁，我可不预测这会持续四天
before every airline in America shut down and there is a national crisis. It does something about it. Right. If there was a hundred and something squirrels in Central Park dying a day, there would be pickets out there who saved the squirrels.
在美国所有航空公司停飞和发生国家危机之前。它会为此做点什么。对。如果中央公园每天有一百多只松鼠死去，就会有抗议者在那里高喊拯救松鼠。
Rightfully so, I'd be one of the picketers. You know what I mean? Like literally. So to me it's just, we can't minimize human life because they're struggling with an addiction. Addictions aren't a personal problem. That's how we've looked at them as society. We've dismissed addiction as, well, they're getting with an addiction. Addictions aren't a personal problem. That's how we've looked at them in society. We've dismissed addiction as,
理所当然，我也会是抗议者之一。你知道我的意思吗？简直如此。所以对我来说，我们不能因为他们正在与毒瘾作斗争而轻视人的生命。毒瘾不是个人问题。这就是我们作为社会看待它们的方式。我们把毒瘾斥为，好吧，他们正在沾染毒瘾。毒瘾不是个人问题。这就是我们作为社会看待它们的方式。我们把毒瘾斥为，
well, they're getting what they deserve. They chose to do those drugs. And it's like, if you don't really understand addiction, then I could see where you would say that. But now we're in a place where everybody knows an addict. Everybody has a friend or a family member who's like, no, that dude was a great guy or a great woman, and then she got on drugs and I didn't recognize her,
好吧，他们罪有应得。他们选择吸毒。这就像，如果你真的不理解毒瘾，那么我能理解你为什么会这么说。但现在我们处在一个每个人都认识瘾君子的时代。每个人都有一个朋友或家人觉得，不，那家伙是个好人或好女人，然后她开始吸毒，我都认不出她了，
couldn't talk to her. Yeah, my brother died, my brother was an alcoholic and he died from it, yeah. So you know, it's totally different. Can you die from chin chin? Because Sean's white knuckling right now. 167 days in a row. I thought that was the number that Sean had
无法和她说话。对，我哥哥死了，我哥哥是个酒鬼，他因此去世了，是的。所以你知道，这完全不同。你会因为下巴死掉吗？因为肖恩现在紧张得要命。连续167天。我以为那是肖恩
had the chicken cow, what was it? Kung Pao chicken. Kung Pao chicken. It's just gonna take you down, Sean. Look at, I can't stop. The wanton chip is incredible. So, Jelly, talk a little bit about, man, so you get out and you decide to make a change
吃过的宫保鸡丁，是什么来着？宫保鸡丁。这会把你击垮的，肖恩。看，我停不下来。云吞薯片太棒了。所以，果冻，聊聊吧，老兄，你出来了，你决定做出改变
because your daughter, and you've been making music, as you alluded to, while you were there, and now you're out and you're going to school and you're working on reestablishing your relationship with your kids and all that stuff. What's the moment, what's the first musical breakthrough moment? What's the moment where you go, oh, wait a second,
因为你的女儿，而且正如你所暗示的，你在里面的时候一直在做音乐，现在你出来了，在上学，在努力恢复你和孩子们的各种关系。什么时候，第一个音乐突破时刻是什么？你什么时候会觉得，哦，等一下，
we might have something. What's the first song, mixtape, what is it? Walk us through that a little bit. Thank you, this is a question I never get asked because this is like a throw throwback. Because I know the tipping point moment, like what Malcolm Gladwell would say was my moment was a song called Save Me.
我们可能有点眉目了。第一首歌是什么，混音带，是什么？带我们稍微了解一下。谢谢，这是一个从没人问过我的问题，因为这就像个复古话题。因为我知道那个转折点，就像马尔科姆·格拉德威尔会说那是我的时刻一样，那是一首叫《拯救我》的歌。
Oh yeah. But what I know was my moment. Because we know our moment before everybody else does, right, like as an artist. Like we know a moment that's like, y'all might not have seen it there but something in me triggered like I got something here yeah I came home and my buddy had had bought a flip can from
哦，是的。但我也知道什么是我的时刻。因为我们比其他任何人都更早知道我们的时刻，对吧，作为一个艺术家。就像我们知道这样一个时刻：你们可能没看到，但我体内的某些东西被触动了，我在这里有东西了，对，我回家了，我哥们买了个翻盖机，来自
Best Buy his name is Chad Arms and he was like hey man they got this new thing called YouTube that came out since you've been incarcerated it was like it's kind of like Facebook but only for videos I was like fire he was like yeah you gotta go to a laptop, right? So he turns on a beat and I just got out of jail. He's like, yo, just start rapping or something. I'll cut it up later. And I put out this thing called the 10-minute freestyle.
百思买，他叫查德·阿姆斯，他说，嘿，老兄，他们出了个新东西叫YouTube，在你入狱期间出来的，它有点像Facebook，但只用于视频。我说，太火了。他说，对，你得去用笔记本电脑，对吧？所以他打开一个节奏，我刚出狱。他说，哟，随便开始说唱什么的。我待会儿剪辑。然后我发布了一个叫10分钟自由说唱的东西。
It got taken down later because I said something about my parole officer and got in trouble. But I'm just like, you know, I'm a young kid out of jail so I'm just talking shit, rapping. And he put it on YouTube and at the time it was called the 10-minute freestyle, and I won't make y'all do the quiz,
它后来被删了，因为我说了一些关于我的假释官的话，惹上了麻烦。但我只是觉得，你知道的，我是一个刚出狱的年轻人，所以我只是在胡说八道，说唱。他把它放到了YouTube上，当时它被称为10分钟自由说唱，我不会让你们做测验的，
I normally go pop quiz, why was it called the 10-minute freestyle? And it's because at the time, YouTube wouldn't let you upload a video longer than 10 minutes. That was the YouTube bandwidth, was 10-minute, 21-second videos. And at the time, they called it viral because it got like 40,000 views.
我通常会出快问快答，为什么它叫10分钟自由说唱？这是因为当时，YouTube不允许你上传超过10分钟的视频。那是YouTube的带宽限制，也就是10分21秒的视频。当时，他们称之为病毒式传播，因为它获得了大约4万次观看。
This is baby YouTube infancy. So I was like, this is it, We're gonna be, this is gonna work. People care, you know? This is like, it was different because when you're passing mixtapes out in the neighborhood, you see the neighborhood caring. But it's like, is somebody outside the neighborhood ever gonna care?
这是婴儿时期的YouTube。所以我当时想，就是这个，我们要，这行得通。人们在乎，你知道吗？这就像，它是不一样的，当你把混音带在街区里散发时，你看到街区在乎。但就像，街区以外的人会真正在乎吗？
So I was like, there's not 40,000 people in my neighborhood. We're hot, this is real. You know what I mean? Wow. Right, you can build an audience and they like what you're doing. People that don't even know you like what you're doing. That's it, yeah. That's powerful.
所以我当时想，我的街区里没有4万人。我们火了，这是真的。你知道我的意思吗？哇。没错，你可以建立一个受众群体，他们喜欢你在做的事。甚至那些根本不认识你的人也喜欢你在做的事。就是这样，是的。这很有力量。
It was easier when people knew you. Like school, in y'all's world maybe like school theater. It's like, yeah, of course, you know, but like when you had to go do it at another high school, it's like, whoa, I might be onto something. I'm not a big hit here. You know what I mean? Yeah, right, right, right.
当人们认识你时，这更容易。就像学校，在你们的世界里也许就像学校戏剧。就像，是的，当然，你知道，但当你不得不去另一所高中表演时，就像，哇，我可能有所收获了。我在这里可不是个大红人。你知道我的意思吗？对，对，对，对。
So you make this YouTube video and you get a little bit of traction early days of YouTube, and then presumably you make some more and you start doing that kind of more. When do you, when do you first start getting like the sniffing around from the corporate entities that like to control these kinds of things and make, and see, they see dollar signs for themselves from you?
所以你做了这个YouTube视频，在YouTube早期获得了一点牵引力，然后大概你做了更多，开始做更多这种事。你什么时候，你什么时候开始受到那些喜欢控制这些事情并赚钱的企业的关注，他们从你身上看到了美元符号？
Man, I tell you how lucky I got, and I think y'all got lucky like this too, is that nobody's seen what was happening until it kind of happened. So like by the time the labels were calling, I was making seven figures a year off my YouTube. Right. Oh wow. You know what I mean?
老兄，我告诉你我有多幸运，我想你们也这么幸运，那就是在事情发生之前，没有人看到发生了什么。所以当唱片公司打电话来的时候，我靠YouTube每年赚七位数。对。哦，哇。你知道我的意思吗？
So by the time they call, it's just like, then they call like, hey, we'll give you a million dollars. I was like, I made that, what are you talking about? Yeah, you're gonna have to come up with something better. know what I mean? It's crazy, I was like, y'all gotta come. So the first call to answer your question directly came in like 2018. We didn't negotiate a deal till 2021. Wow.
所以当他们打电话来时，就像是，然后他们打电话说，嘿，我们给你一百万美元。我说，我都赚了，你在说什么？是的，你们得拿出更好的东西。你知道我的意思吗？太疯狂了，我说，你们得来。所以为了直接回答你的问题，第一个电话大约在2018年打进来。我们直到2021年才谈妥一笔交易。哇。
Because they kept coming, I was like, I don't think, y'all see the metrics, but y'all aren't. When I finally signed my record deal, I love talking about inside baseball, how the sausage is made, it's my favorite. I know, it's so good. Yeah, we do too. We do too. We do too.
因为他们不断地来，我说，我不认为，你们看到了数据，但你们没有。当我最终签下唱片合约时，我喜欢谈论内幕消息，香肠是怎么做出来的，这是我的最爱。我知道，太棒了。是的，我们也一样。我们也一样。我们也一样。
So we love it. Yeah, when I finally signed my record deal, I had already had 3 million or 2.5 million YouTube subscribers, a billion views on my YouTube channel. Wow, amazing. I'd already had a couple of gold records independently. I was selling two to 4,000 tickets everywhere in the Midwest and Southeast, everywhere in the Bible Belt
所以我们很喜欢。是的，当我最终签下唱片合约时，我已经拥有300万或250万YouTube订阅者，我的YouTube频道有十亿次观看。哇，太惊人了。我已经独立拥有了几张金唱片。我在中西部和东南部到处卖出2000到4000张门票，到处都在圣经带
or the Rust Belt. If it ended with belt, we were killing there. You know what I mean? So it's like, you know, once we got left of Colorado, we, you know what I'm saying? But we knew we'd work our way out here eventually. It's a- Left of Colorado.
或铁锈带。如果以带结尾，我们在那里大杀四方。你知道我的意思吗？所以，你知道，一旦我们过了科罗拉多州以西，我们，你知道我在说什么吗？但我们知道我们最终会一路来到这里。这是一个- 科罗拉多州以西。
So by the time they started sniffing around, I was like, look, here's kind of where we are and I got the deal I dreamed of. Right, yeah, exactly. Because they had to do something better than what you're ever doing. How about this, y'all know, y'all will get this, I own 100% of my master recordings,
所以当他们开始四处打听时，我说，听着，这就是我们的现状，我得到了我梦想中的合约。对，没错，正好。因为他们必须做得比你正在做的更好。这样吧，你们知道的，你们会懂的，我拥有我母带录音100%的版权，
I own 100% of my publishing, I own my IP completely, I own everything to do with who I am as me. And now you have a whole library that you can hold onto for the rest of your life, pass it on to your daughter or whatever you want to do with who I am as me. And now you have a whole library that is, you can hold onto for the rest of your life, pass it on to your daughter or whatever you wanna do. Yeah. Yep, put, just, you know what I did with it,
我拥有我出版物100%的版权，我完全拥有我的知识产权，我拥有与我作为我自己的身份有关的一切。现在你拥有了一个完整的曲库，你可以为你的余生保留，传给你的女儿或任何你想用我作为我自己的身份做的事情。现在你拥有了一个完整的曲库，你可以为你的余生保留，传给你的女儿或任何你想做的事情。是的。没错，把，你知道我对它做了什么，
paid the taxes on early and put it in the trust and let it grow. Yeah. Put the catalog there for the family. Let them, I broke generational curses, baby. Yeah. How did you, and then so you jumped into that community of,
提前交了税，把它放进信托基金让它增长。是的。把目录留给家人。让他们，我打破了世代的诅咒，宝贝。是的。你是怎么，然后你就跳进了那个，
I'll say in quotes, legitimacy, right? Where you're now you're at these shows with all of these sort of established acts and these record labels and all of the sort of the infrastructure. How have you found that community? Because you came from such a- Yeah, you're an outlier.
我打引号说是合法的社群，对吧？你在那里，你和所有这些老牌艺人、唱片公司以及所有这些基础设施一起参加这些演出。你觉得那个社群怎么样？因为你来自一个如此——是的，你是个局外人。
Yeah, and you're the real deal. And how has that merged with you and how have you merged with them? It's been great. It's been really cool. My deal from the beginning was, look man, I'll trust y'all if y'all trust me. So, you know, let's just not question each other at all.
是的，你是真材实料的。这与你如何融合，你与他们如何融合？这很棒。真的很酷。我从一开始的交易就是，听着，老兄，如果你们信任我，我就信任你们。所以，你知道，我们根本不要互相质疑。
So when y'all ask for something, I'm not going to question y'all. Y'all know what y'all are doing. But equally, if I tell you I want to put out an album a year or 30 songs on an album, or I start making some of these what might seem like crazy artistic choices, I was like, you just got to let me ride my wave.
所以当你们要求什么时，我不会质疑你们。你们知道自己在做什么。但同样地，如果我告诉你们我想一年发一张专辑，或者一张专辑里有30首歌，或者我开始做一些可能看起来很疯狂的艺术选择，我说，你们只需要让我顺其自然。
This is what I've been doing. This is just the way I operate. You know, I came into a label that was used to doing at the time two year, three year album cycles, I was like, you just gotta let me ride my wave. This is what I've been doing. This is just the way I operate. I came into a label that was used to doing, at the time, two year, three year album cycles, and I put out an album a year for the first three years on my deal. I just came in at a totally different pace.
这就是我一直在做的。这就是我的运作方式。你知道，我加入了一家习惯于当时做两年、三年专辑周期的唱片公司，我说，你们只需要让我顺其自然。这就是我一直在做的事。这就是我的运作方式。我加入了一家唱片公司，在当时习惯于两年、三年的专辑周期，而我在合约的前三年里每年出一张专辑。我以完全不同的节奏加入了进来。
Well, they're smart to listen to you because more people in those positions should listen to the artist. I mean, you're you because of who you are. You'll make them the money they're looking for if you just leave you alone. And it's born fruit. You've had these number one singles.
好吧，他们听你的很聪明，因为那些位子上的人应该更多地听艺术家的。我的意思是，因为你是谁，所以你才是你。如果你不理他，他就会赚到他们想要的钱。它已经开花结果了。你有了这些冠军单曲。
You've had, I mean, your single, I Am Not Okay, or I mean, which is a great song. It's such a great song. As I alluded to in the intro, it deals with, you know, ideas of mental health and really talking about it openly. I love that song, dude. I think that it's really powerful and inspirational. But that thing, that was a massive hit.
你有，我的意思是，你的单曲《我不好》，或者我的意思是，这是一首很棒的歌。这是一首非常棒的歌。正如我在开场所暗示的，它处理了心理健康的概念，并真正公开地谈论它。我喜欢那首歌，老兄。我认为它真的很有力量和启发性。但那首歌，那是个巨大的热门。
And that came, that's the record label trusting you and you going, I know what I'm doing. And then you put a song like that out that just explodes. For sure. That must've felt vindicating. Like, I know what I'm doing. It felt great, especially with the label because I'm like, I just came off the song, Save Me've felt vindicating, like, I know what I'm doing. It felt great, especially with the label,
那是唱片公司信任你，而你却说，我知道我在做什么。然后你推出了一首像这样的歌，瞬间火了。肯定的。那一定让人觉得是一种证明。就像，我知道我在做什么。感觉太棒了，尤其是对唱片公司来说，因为我想，我刚推出一首歌，叫《拯救我》，
because I'm like, I just came off the song Save Me With Lainey, which was a huge hit for me, but it was a big ballad. So here I am going back to the label, I'm like, hey look, I don't wanna turn, I know y'all are gonna think I'm the male Adele here, but it's like, I've got another big ballad that I love. You know what I'm saying?
和莱妮合作的，对我来说是个巨大的热门，但那是一首大抒情歌。所以我现在回到唱片公司，我说，嘿，听着，我不想变成，我知道你们会认为我是男版阿黛尔，但就像，我还有另一首我很喜欢的大抒情歌。你知道我在说什么吗？
I was like, I think it's gonna touch people. You know what I'm saying? Madel is a good song. Yeah, Madel, ah, take? I was like, I think it's gonna touch people. You know what I'm saying? Yeah, Modell, ah, take that one, Sean, I'll steal it. What if I named my album that? Forgive my naivete, but if I'm a label and I no longer have to print albums and cassettes and DVD or CDs or whatever the hell it is,
我说，我认为这会触动人们。你知道我在说什么吗？马黛尔是一首好歌。是的，马黛尔，啊，拿走？我说，我认为这会触动人们。你知道我在说什么吗？是的，莫戴尔，啊，拿走那个，肖恩，我偷了。如果我把我的专辑命名为那个会怎么样？原谅我的天真，但如果我是一家唱片公司，我不再需要印刷专辑、磁带、DVD或CD或诸如此类的鬼东西，
what would be the burden that I would have to bear if my artist wants to put out an album a year? In other words, how much do I have to spend as a label because you're making the music and then you just put it out digitally, is there, what would give them pause to have that kind of frequency? You know?
如果我的艺术家想一年出一张专辑，我必须承担什么负担？换句话说，作为一家唱片公司我得花多少钱，因为你做音乐然后以数字方式发布，有什么会让暂停这种频率？你知道吗？
Spot on. What would be the biggest pause have that kind of frequency? You know? Spot on. What would be the biggest pause for most artists, not me, is that they need their money. So every time they're going to record a new album, they gotta tap in and go, hey, I need a million dollars. Oh, I see. To record this record. They just gotta pay you your fee.
完全正确。对于大多数艺术家来说，最大的暂停会有这种频率的原因是什么，不是我，是他们需要钱。所以每次他们要去录制新专辑时，他们都得介入并说，嘿，我需要一百万美元。哦，我明白了。来录制这张唱片。他们只需要付给你你的费用。
So that's, but are they fronting you that fee that they then can claw back with the sales? Gotcha. And at the rate of the deal, it's the worst thing in the music business. I've been preaching against this for so long. I refuse to do it. That's why I don't take their money at all.
所以这就是，但他们是在预支你这笔他们随后可以用销售额收回的费用吗？明白了。按照这笔交易的比例，这是音乐界最糟糕的事情。我为此宣讲了太久。我拒绝这么做。这就是为什么我根本不拿他们的钱。
Right, is that because in any other business, what the record businesses do to artists would be illegal. Right, like if a bank did it or a car lot did it, they'd shut them down. Okay. Because, because what is it? Because you're not allowed to put an interest rate on that kind of money.
对，是因为在任何其他行业中，唱片公司对艺术家所做的事情都是违法的。对，就像如果银行这样做或车行这样做，他们就会关门大吉。好吧。因为，因为是什么？因为你不能对那种钱加收利率。
Right. But if you don't call it a loan, you call it an advance. Mm-hmm. Right, so when I take the word loan out of it, I call it an advance, and then we recoup it at the rate of the deal. So let's say, Jason, excuse me. Do you need to blow your nose, Sean? Can you run over there real quick?
对。但如果你不称它为贷款，你称它为预付款。嗯哼。对，所以当我把贷款这个词去掉，我称它为预付款，然后我们按照交易的比例收回它。所以假设，杰森，不好意思。你需要擤鼻涕吗，肖恩？你能快点跑过去吗？
Thank you, Sean. Let's say y'all three do a smartless album, right? Sure. What instrument would each of us play? Go ahead and assign us each an instrument. Okay, everybody gets an instrument. I think this would be something unique. What would it strike you as?
谢谢你，肖恩。假设你们三个做一个“聪明人”专辑，对吧？当然。我们每个人会演奏什么乐器？来吧，给我们每个人指定一件乐器。好吧，每个人都有一个乐器。我认为这将是独一无二的。你会觉得它像什么？
You look like you could rock a saxophone. That's hurtful. It could be a really cool curve ball to see you with a saxophone. I would love to see, just because I think this would be so out of pocket for the crew, is if Sean was like the electric guitar player and he carried like a big,
你看上去能驾驭萨克斯。这很伤人。看到你拿着萨克斯可能会是一个非常酷的转折点。我很想看到，只是因为我认为这对于这个团队来说太不着边际了，如果肖恩就像是电吉他手，他背着一个巨大的、
just gaudy, Gretsch, just one of them huge, oversized guitars. And then wheels on the keytar? No, you gotta have a drummer. Yeah. You know what I mean? It's not a drummer. He fancies himself a drummer.
花哨的格列奇吉他，那种巨大、超大的吉他之一。然后键盘吉他上的轮子？不，你得有个鼓手。是的。你知道我的意思吗？不是鼓手。他自认为是鼓手。
The most athletic of us, yeah. The youngest queuingwing most athletic. And I'm just blowing things. Just stick with what you're good at, dude. Blowing air. Wet my reed. All right, so. But pretend y'all get the deal.
我们中最具运动神经的，对吧。最年轻、最有运动神经的。而我只是在吹气。坚持你擅长的，老兄。吹气。润湿我的簧片。好吧，所以。但假设你们得到了这笔交易。
Pretend y'all get the deal, right? And I say, it's a 70-30 deal, 70% in the favor of the label, 30% for y'all, then I'll give you a million dollars to record the first Smartless deal, right? And I say, it's a 70-30 deal, 70% in the favor of the label, 30% for y'all, then I'll give you a million dollars to record the first Smartless album, right? They're like, okay, we get 10% apiece, they're putting up all the money, you sign the deal.
假设你们得到了这笔交易，对吧？我说，这是一笔70-30的交易，70%归唱片公司，30%归你们，然后我给你们一百万美元来录制第一张“聪明人”专辑，对吧？他们会说，好吧，我们每人分到10%，他们出了所有的钱，你签了这笔交易。
But the problem is, I recoup at the rate of the deal, which means every time Smartless makes a dollar, I take 70 cents of that dollar, and I go, this is mine, that was our deal. You're like, yep, and then I go now this would be your 30 cents But I'm gonna put this 30 cents towards the million dollars you owe me Right. Wow Yeah, that's a that's that is a 70% interest rate gentlemen. I don't care how you slice or butter that bread. Yeah
但问题是，我按照交易比例收回成本，这意味着每当“聪明人”赚到一美元时，我拿走那一美元中的70美分，我说，这是我的，那是我们的交易。你会说，对，然后我说现在这将是你的30美分，但我要把这30美分用于偿还你欠我的一百万美元，对。哇。是的，那是70%的利率，先生们。不管你怎么切或者怎么给面包抹黄油，都是这样。是的。
Now you could you found legal loopholes to make it not that but ultimately that's absurd, you know the name. Yeah We'll be right back And now back to the show Now let me ask you something how did you become so savvy did you have did you have your pitfalls along the way and you learn and and This is the result of that is now you're like, I know how to do deals now because you must have made some bad ones
现在你可以，你找到了法律漏洞让它不变成那样，但归根结底这是荒谬的，你知道名字。是的，我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。现在让我问你一件事，你是怎么变得如此精明的？这一路上你有没有遇到过陷阱，然后你吸取教训，这就是结果，现在你就像，我知道现在怎么谈交易了，因为你肯定做过一些糟糕的交易
in order to know what good ones are. Yeah, well, that's what happened. And ultimately, the cool thing was nobody wanted to sign me. So like when nobody wants to work with you, but you're like, I had to figure it out myself. Right, so you had to make it yourself and by the time they came to you and they're like, hey, here's how the deals are, you're like,
为了知道什么是好的交易。是的，好吧，那就是发生的事情。归根结底，最酷的事情是没人想签我。所以当没有人想和你合作时，你会想，我不得不自己想办法。对，所以你不得不自己去搞定，当他们来找你并说，嘿，交易是这样的，你会说，
hang on a second, the math doesn't add up. I don't need your fucking money under your system. I'm making plenty on my own. Right, when you, yeah, when you kind of see that, when you see that math up front, you go like, uh-uh. Yeah, no, as soon as you see it, and then you're aware, because I've done enough distribution deals, and early in my career, I had to take a little money, so you'd go get 100 it, and then you're aware, because I've done enough distribution deals. And early in my career, I had to take a little money.
等一下，这数学不对。在你们的系统下，我不需要你们他妈的钱。我自己赚得够多了。对，当你，是的，当你看到这一点时，当你一眼看出那个数学时，你会说，不，不。是的，不，一旦你看到了，然后你意识到了，因为我做了足够的发行交易，在我的职业生涯早期，我不得不拿一点钱，所以你会去拿10万，
So you'd go get 100 grand, and then you'd see it took you six months to pay the 100 grand back. And you're like, by the time I paid the 100 grand back, they made a half a million dollars. I was like, I'm trippin'. This is, you know, it wasn't even, you go through that enough times that when it finally happens, the label calls,
然后你会发现你花了六个月才把10万还清。你会想，等我把10万还清的时候，他们赚了五十万美元。我想，我是疯了吗。这，你知道，甚至都不是，你经历了足够多次，以至于最终发生时，唱片公司打电话来，
hey, we'll give you, and that's where labels kept messing up. The first three or four labels, oh, I love talking about this, the first three or four labels that would call me would just offer me money. They thought I was just some dumb redneck, which they were right,
嘿，我们会给你，这就是唱片公司不断搞砸的地方。前三四家唱片公司，哦，我喜欢谈论这个，前三四家打电话给我的唱片公司只是给我钱。他们以为我只是个笨蛋红脖子，他们没猜错，
but they thought I was a dumber redneck than they thought I was. And they would come and they'd be like, hey, you know, listen, I'll never forget one label said, it's a blank check. Like, whatever you want it to be within reason, you put the amount of money you want us to give you and then we'll put a number of albums with it.
但他们以为我比他们想象的还要蠢。他们会来，然后说，嘿，你知道，听着，我永远不会忘记有一家唱片公司说，这是一张空白支票。就像，无论你在合情合理的范围内想要多少，你写下你想让我们给你的金额，然后我们随之附上专辑的数量。
Right, gotcha. You know, and I had a guy at the time who was ill advising me, who was like, let's just ask for like 10 or 20 million bucks, dude. This will change both of our lives forever. He was like kind of managing me a little bit. I was like, right then I was like, I think I need to find another manager.
对，明白了。你知道，当时我有一个给我出馊主意的人，他说，老兄，我们去要个1000万或2000万美元吧。这会永远改变我们两个人的生活。他当时有点在管理我。我当时就想，我觉得我得换个经纪人了。
You know what I'm saying? I was like, I don't think this is right. I was like, cause I'm need to find another manager. You know what I'm saying? I was like, I don't think this is right. I was like, cause I'm also in a space where, you know, mama didn't raise no fool. You know what I mean? It's like, I was smart enough to go, I don't, if they think I can make $20 million, and that's what these people do is they count beans
你知道我在说什么吗？我当时想，我觉得这不对。我当时想，因为我也在一个空间里，你知道，妈妈可没养傻子。你知道我的意思吗？就像，我足够聪明，会想，我不，如果他们认为我能赚2000万美元，而这些人所做的就是数豆子
and determine if people can make $20 million, I think I can make $20 million. You know what I'm saying? I was like, maybe I'm crazy to think that, but you know what I mean? I was like, they should know bigger. No, they showed their cards. Yeah, exactly.
并确定人们是否能赚2000万美元，我认为我能赚2000万美元。你知道我在说什么吗？我当时想，也许我这么想是疯了，但你知道我的意思吗？我当时想，他们应该知道得更多。不，他们亮底牌了。对，完全正确。
Anytime somebody comes at you with a number and says, hey, this out of the blue and says, this is what we want to give you, you're like, all right, this is a great starting point. They're obviously worth way more than that. They're building in a pad that's favorable to them. We've had our own experience with that ourselves. But now, so the industry standard on the deal structure
每当有人带着一个数字来找你，说，嘿，这突如其来地说，这就是我们想给你的，你会想，好吧，这是一个很好的起点。他们的价值显然远不止于此。他们建立了一个对他们有利的垫层。我们自己也有过这样的经历。但现在，关于现场演出的行业标准交易结构
for live performance, so touring and stuff like that, is much more in the favor of the artist, is that correct? Yeah, well, yeah, always. Ancillary participation is what they call it, to try to get us away from the 360 deal, which is what it is still, they just gave it a cooler name. But it's always in favor of the artist, depending on what your deal was
对于巡演之类的东西，对艺术家更有利，对吗？是的，嗯，是的，一直都是。辅助参与是他们对它的称呼，试图让我们摆脱360度协议，这仍然是那种协议，他们只是给它起了一个更酷的名字。但它总是对艺术家有利，这取决于你的交易是什么
and how much money you took. I know some artists in town that did bad ancillary deals too though. They did like 50-50 or 70-30 ancillaries. So they're in this 80-20 record deal where they're only getting 20% of their streaming royalties, don't own any of the masters. 100% of the masters will own by the label
以及你拿了多少钱。不过我也知道城里有些艺术家做过糟糕的辅助交易。他们做了诸如50-50或70-30的辅助交易。所以他们陷入了这个80-20的唱片交易中，他们只能得到20%的流媒体版税，没有任何母带的所有权。母带的100%将由唱片公司拥有
for the rest of their careers. Wow, right, right, that's crazy. And then they go out and they'll do a 60, 40 ancillary participation. And the problem with that is. Meaning the concerts? Yeah, but the problem with that is is that if I give the label even 80%,
在他们职业生涯的剩余时间里。哇，对，对，太疯狂了。然后他们出去做60-40的辅助参与。这其中的问题在于。意思是音乐会？是的，但问题在于，如果我甚至给唱片公司80%，
let's say, I mean 20%, let's say I said, you know what, we've done great, y'all built my profile, I'll give you 20%. Booking agent wants 10. Management's still coming in at 15. Business manager's still at five, which I've negotiated all those fees back over the years, but I mean, you know how this works.
比方说，我的意思是20%，比方说我说，你知道吗，我们做得很好，你们打造了我的形象，我给你们20%。预订经纪人想要10%。管理层依然占15%。商业经纪人依然占5%，虽然我多年来已经把这些费用都谈判回来了，但我的意思是，你知道这是怎么运作的。
I mean, if you just, next thing you know, what I try to advise artists is this, you're gonna end up in a situation where you're gonna make what your manager's making if you're not careful. You know what I mean? You're gonna look one day, when you and your manager move
我的意思是，如果你只是，接下来你知道的，我试图给艺术家的建议是这样的，如果你不小心，你最终会落入一个你赚的钱和你的经纪人差不多的境地。你知道我的意思吗？你有一天会发现，当你和你的经纪人搬到
in the same neighborhood together, you're in trouble. You know what I'm saying? You get to keep all the merchandise money, how does that work? It's normally in the S-layers. Same ratio? But yeah, just whatever that is.
同一个街区时，你就麻烦了。你知道我在说什么吗？你能保留所有的周边商品钱吗，那是怎么运作的？通常在S层。相同的比例？但是的，不管那是什么。
It's ticket sales? It's out of mind completely. Do you feel like you have to tour whether that's emotionally, financially, spiritually, or do you want to tour? Because I ask people this often who come on the show, who are musicians or in bands, because I'm such a homebody,
是门票销售？完全抛诸脑后。你觉得你必须去巡演吗，无论是情感上、财务上、精神上，还是你想去巡演？因为我经常问来节目的音乐人或乐队成员这个问题，因为我非常恋家，
like whenever I have to go anywhere and pack and then shack up at a hotel. Pack is the reason. Yeah, like pack a suitcase. The idea of going out and learning in the world is really what really holds me back is the idea that I have to fucking pack. Hire somebody to fucking pack for me.
就像每当我必须去任何地方收拾行李并在酒店安顿下来时。收拾行李是原因。是的，比如收拾行李箱。出去了解世界的想法，真正阻碍我的是我必须他妈的收拾行李。雇个人帮我他妈的收拾行李。
I hate packing. You're not learning anything at your fucking house. Jesus Christ. Maybe I am. Both you guys, I'm gonna bury you both. I'm learning a lot today. It's the idea ofhing in a strange room. Oh, jeez.
我讨厌收拾行李。你在你他妈的家里什么也学不到。耶稣基督。也许我有。你们两个，我要把你们两个都埋了。我今天学到了很多。这是一种在一个陌生的房间里的想法。哦，天哪。
No, well the whole point of all of that was I'm such a homebody, I can't imagine going on tour all the time every year. So different way of saying he's lazy, by the way. Yeah, exactly, what's that like for you? Well, I think it's a need and a want. I need to write music. That's something I know.
不，这一切的重点是我太恋家了，我无法想象每年总是去巡演。顺便说一句，这是他懒惰的另一种说法。对，准确地说，这对你来说是什么样的？嗯，我认为这既是需求也是渴望。我需要写音乐。这是我知道的事。
For like my spirit and my therapy, like I have to write songs. Like I have, there's something in me. I'm very, very empathic. I meet people every day. I hear these stories about how my music has helped people through dark moments and that stuff sits with me.
为了我的精神和治疗，比如我必须写歌。比如我必须，我体内有些东西。我非常、非常有同理心。我每天都会遇到人。我听到这些故事，关于我的音乐如何帮助人们度过黑暗时刻，那些东西留在我心里。
I don't find a way to exercise that. Touring for me is just the old school, like I'm an old school rock and roll dude, man. I still smoke pot and play the guitar a couple hours every day just for fun if I can. You know what I mean? I can still just get lost in jamming and learning other people's songs.
我找不到宣泄的方法。对我来说，巡演只是老派的，就像我是一个老派的摇滚老兄，老兄。如果可以的话，我每天仍然抽大麻弹吉他几个小时，纯粹为了好玩。你知道我的意思吗？我仍然可以沉迷于即兴演奏和学习别人的歌。
Like I love this life. I love the pace. I love the bus. I love the smell of diesel fuel. I love pilot truck stops at 6 a.m., Sean. I mean, I love all that stuff. You know what I mean? That stuff is the stuff that does something for me.
就像我热爱这种生活。我喜欢这个节奏。我喜欢大巴。我喜欢柴油燃料的气味。我喜欢早上6点的领航卡车休息站，肖恩。我的意思是，我喜欢所有这些东西。你知道我的意思吗？这些东西才是真正能为我做点什么的东西。
Sean does too, different reasons. Yeah, in my 20s, different reason for truck stops. It was change, yeah. What was it like, what was the moment when you got that first Grammy nomination? What was... Oh, I cried, baby. Snot rocket crying.
肖恩也是，原因不同。是的，在我20多岁时，去卡车休息站的原因不同。那是为了零钱，是的。那是什么感觉，当你获得第一个格莱美提名时，那个时刻是怎样的？那是……哦，我哭了，宝贝。哭得鼻涕眼泪一大把。
Did you? Oh, nasty, couldn't quit crying. Then I called my mama to tell her, and I videoed myself calling her, and my mama's a little older, you know? So I'm like, mama, I just got nominated. I'm snot rocketed, so she can't hear me. I'm just blowing snot bubbles, and she goes,
是吗？哦，恶心，根本停不下来。然后我打电话给妈妈告诉她，我录下了自己给她打电话的过程，我妈妈有点老了，你知道吗？所以我说，妈妈，我刚获得提名。我鼻涕眼泪直流，所以她听不清我说话。我只是在吹鼻涕泡，她说，
you said something about some money? I said, no, mama, I said the Grammys. She said, but you said your granny? I said, no, mama, I said the Grammys. She said, you said your granny? I said, no, mama, I said I just got nominated for a Grammy. And she's so funny, she goes, well, that's good. And then two seconds later, she goes, hey, I seen a picture of you and Tanya Tucker together. How cool was she?
你刚才说什么钱？我说，不，妈妈，我说的是格莱美。她说，但你刚才说你的奶奶？我说，不，妈妈，我说的是格莱美。她说，你刚才说你的奶奶？我说，不，妈妈，我说我刚获得格莱美提名。她太搞笑了，她说，哦，那挺好。然后两秒钟后，她说，嘿，我看到你和谭雅·塔克在一起的照片了。她有多酷？
I'm still crying. And my mama's asking about Tanya Tucker, the country singer. She had seen a picture of us together on the internet. She's like, what's up with Tanya Tucker though? But it was cool, man. It was, in our business, it don't get no bigger, man. The easiest way to describe it is, I've been blessed to win a CMA.
我还在哭。而我妈妈在问关于谭雅·塔克的事，那个乡村歌手。她在网上看到了一张我们在一起的照片。她就像，不过谭雅·塔克是怎么回事？但那很酷，老兄。那是，在我们的行业里，没有比这更大的了，老兄。最简单的描述是，我很幸运赢得了CMA。
I've been blessed to win an ACM. I've been blessed to win a CMP. You swept the CMAs, right? I mean, you cleaned up. I've had some big moments. And being nominated for a Grammy, just the nomination trumps all those. Sure, yeah.
我很幸运赢得了ACM。我很幸运赢得了CMP。你横扫了CMA，对吧？我的意思是，你大获全胜。我经历过一些高光时刻。而获得格莱美提名，仅仅是提名就胜过所有这些。当然，是的。
Before I got nominated for a Grammy, I was introduced as the CMA, ACM award-winning, multi-platinum recording artist. Right. I am now introduced real easy. Grammy nominated, recording artist, jelly girl. Just being nominated, got every award I'd ever want even being in my title.
在我获得格莱美提名之前，人们介绍我是CMA、ACM获奖的多白金唱片艺术家。对。我现在介绍起来非常容易。获得格莱美提名的录音艺术家，果冻女孩。仅仅是获得提名，就让我得到了我想要的所有奖项，甚至能把它们写进我的头衔里。
You know what I'm saying? Like that's how cool it is. So who would you be most excited to meet at a big event? Like say like the Grammys or something like that. Ooh, that's a good one because at the last Grammys I got to meet Taylor. Taylor Swift came and talked to me and I felt like the belle of the ball, dog.
你知道我在说什么吗？就像那有多酷。那么在大型活动中，你最期待见到谁？比如像格莱美或类似的地方？哦，这是一个好问题，因为在上一届格莱美上我见到了泰勒。泰勒·斯威夫特来跟我说话，我觉得自己就像舞会里的绝代佳人，老兄。
When I tell you I felt like king shit. I felt dog. When I tell you, I felt like king shit. I felt the same way I felt when Howard Stern hugged me. Right, when Howard hugged me, I was like, dude, this dude likes me for real. I'm looking and Taylor's walking across the room and it's like, this is Taylor Swift, so you're just watching people part like the Red Sea. They're just like, and as she's walking,
当我告诉你我感觉自己像个大人物时。我觉得自己像个老兄。当我告诉你时，我觉得自己像个大人物。我有一种当年霍华德·斯特恩拥抱我时的感觉。对，当霍华德拥抱我时，我想，老兄，这家伙是真的喜欢我。我看着泰勒走过房间，就像，这是泰勒·斯威夫特，所以你只是看着人们像红海一样分开。他们就像，当她走过来时，
and my wife grabs me, she goes, I think Taylor's walking over here. I was like, no, no, and I'm looking at her and she's looking at me and I was like, no, I think she's walking to my wife, and she goes, I think Taylor's walking over here. I was like, no, no, and I'm looking at her, and she's looking at me, and I was like, no, I think she's walking over to Boy Wonder, because Boy Wonder was sitting, Boy Genius was sitting in front of me. And I think she's walking over to Boy Genius.
我妻子抓住我，她说，我觉得泰勒朝这边走过来了。我说，不，不，我看着她，她看着我，我说，不，我觉得她是走向我妻子，她说，我觉得泰勒朝这边走过来了。我说，不，不，我看着她，她看着我，我说，不，我觉得她是走向“天才小子”，因为“天才小子”坐在，男孩天才坐在我前面。我想她是走向男孩天才的。
And she did, she walked right up to me, gave me a hug, it was super cool. I was like, I'm so excited. That's amazing. And then I was so nervous, I fumbled. I forgot, I was gonna tell her this great emotional story about how I pushed my daughter on the swing set of the park she built in her old hometown, and I just could not remember. I forgot, I was gonna tell her this great emotional story about how I pushed my daughter on the swing set
她确实去了，她径直走到我面前，给了我一个拥抱，超级酷。我当时想，我太激动了。太惊人了。然后我太紧张了，我搞砸了。我忘了，我本来要告诉她一个非常感人的故事，关于我如何在她家乡建造的公园的秋千上推我的女儿。而我就是想不起来了。我忘了，我本来要告诉她一个非常感人的故事，关于我如何在公园的秋千上推我的女儿，
of the park she built in her old hometown. And I just could not remember it. I was like, the park, my daughter, I was like, it was just so bad. You'll get that chance again, I'm sure. I got to meet Jay-Z there too, it was really cool. Stevie Wonder, I mean, it was like, it was definitely, Ed Sheeran came and talked to me, I mean,
那个公园是她在她以前的家乡建造的。我就是想不起来了。我当时想，公园，我的女儿，我当时想，真是太糟糕了。你以后还会有那个机会的，我确信。我也在那里见到了Jay-Z，真的很酷。史提夫·旺达，我的意思是，这绝对是，艾德·希兰来跟我聊天，我的意思是，
it was really cool. All good people, yeah. Yeah, that is so cool. You know, it's funny, I was thinking about your song, well, I'm Not Okay, but Save Me, and all your songs, and Son of a Sinner, and I got to hang out with a singer-songwriter a few months ago. We were out late night, and he was playing all his songs, but acoustically,
真的很酷。都是很好的人，对。对，太酷了。你知道，这很有趣，我之前在想你的歌，好吧，不是《I'm Not Okay》，而是《Save Me》，还有你的所有歌，以及《Son of a Sinner》，几个月前我和一位创作歌手一起出去玩。我们很晚才出去，他弹了所有的歌，但是是不插电的（木吉他版），
there were a bunch of us in this room. And I was like, and when I was listening to him play these songs acoustically and singing with the power and the emotion, I was like, these are the poets of our time. Country music has become, they speak about the heart of what's going on. and when you listen to the lyrics and you listen to the passion, especially in an acoustic
房间里有我们的一群人。然后我想，当我听他用木吉他弹奏这些歌曲，并带着力量和情感演唱时，我想，这就是我们这个时代的诗人。乡村音乐已经变成了，他们直击事情的核心。当你倾听歌词，聆听那种激情，特别是在不插电的
setting, I found it in, when it was like really stripped down, it blew my mind, man. I was so moved by this. It was probably a guy, do you know Thomas Rhett? It was- Of course, T.R. is my buddy. Yeah, I was with Thomas and he was playing and he was playing some of his songs
环境下，我发现，当音乐被极度简化时，我的天哪，这震撼到我了。我为此深受感动。这可能是一个人，你知道托马斯·瑞特（Thomas Rhett）吗？那是——当然了，T.R.是我的好哥们。对，我和托马斯在一起，他在弹奏，他弹了他的一些歌，
and he was playing some of lots of other people's songs as well, man, it was, and it's true. I mean, I don't know how much you guys, Sean and JB have listened to a lot of the country that's coming out now and the stuff that, it's unbelievable, man. Yeah, a little good. Yeah, it's all good.
他还弹了许多其他人的歌，伙计，真是这样，而且千真万确。我的意思是，我不知道你们俩，肖恩和JB，听了多少现在新出的乡村音乐以及那些作品，简直令人难以置信，伙计。对，挺不错的。对，都挺不错的。
It's all good stuff. Well, you gotta think, all the poets have always ended up in Nashville. Bob Dylan went out of his way to come down here and write and do Nashville Skyline. One of the only places James Taylor frequented besides his island of his own where he rode out up on the Northeast was he'd come to Nashville
都是好作品。好吧，你想想，所有的诗人都最终汇聚到了纳什维尔。鲍勃·迪伦特意来到这里创作并制作了《Nashville Skyline》。詹姆斯·泰勒除了常去他自己在东北部的私人小岛外，他唯一经常光顾的地方之一就是来纳什维尔
every now and then. Like, it's always kind of leaned that way. And I think that we're having the biggest moment we've ever had with it. But what you get to experience is what I tell people that makes country music more special than every genre is that it's all about the song with us. Like, it's all about the hits with the other genres.
偶尔待待。所以，这里总是倾向于这种氛围。而且我认为我们正在经历它有史以来最辉煌的时刻。但你能体验到的是，我经常告诉人们，这让乡村音乐比其他任何流派都更特别，那就是对我们来说，一切都关于歌曲本身。就像在其他流派中，一切都关于热门单曲一样。
Like, not in a bad way, but like, you know, it's a lot of production, it's a very produced thing. But like, in our business is, if I take all that shit out and I just grab my guitar right now, or if I grab this piano right now and I break this song down, just me and you acoustic, it really makes the song stand out. Right, and what you're talking about, yeah.
这倒不是说不好，但你知道的，那有很多制作，是非常工业化的产物。但在我们这一行里，如果我把那些乱七八糟的东西都拿掉，现在就拿起我的吉他，或者现在就拿起这架钢琴，把这首歌拆解开，就我和你进行不插电的演唱，这真的会让歌曲脱颖而出。没错，你说的就是这个，对。
It's incredible. I was so moved in a way that it was really unexpected, man. No, dude, especially when you get to do it like that. Like, when we're all, the best is when you get three or four or five of us in a room together and we're playing past the guitar. Oh, ha ha, that's pretty cool. It's awesome when we're like, yo, what did you write?
这太不可思议了。我深受感动，以一种非常意想不到的方式，伙计。不，老兄，特别是当你能以这种方式表演时。就像我们所有人聚在一起时，最棒的时刻就是三四个或五个人在一个房间里传着弹吉他。哦，哈哈，这太酷了。当我们在说，嘿，你写了什么？
He's like, yo, I wrote this last week and then Thomas Rhett's singing a song that might not ever come out that he just wrote. And then I'm singing a song I might not ever put out that I just wrote, because it's like anything else, I just wrote it, so I think it's the best song I ever wrote. I gotta listen to it for two months before I'm like, this song's not that good.
他说，嘿，我上周写了这个，然后托马斯·瑞特就开始唱一首他刚写的、可能永远都不会发行的歌。然后我也唱一首我刚写的、可能永远都不会拿出来的歌，因为就像其他事情一样，我刚写完它，所以我觉得这是我写过最好的歌。我得听上两个月，才会觉得，其实这歌没那么好。
Listen, I'm not trying to create my own private concert for me, but what I would like to do, and my dream would be to come to like Nashville and hang out with you and tell them, what a great guy, you guys would love him too, right? He's such a great guy, right? Jelly and he's the awesome, what a talent.
听着，我不是想在这里办我自己的私人演唱会，但我想要做的是，我的梦想就是来到纳什维尔和你一起玩，并告诉大家，他是个多棒的人，你们也会爱死他的，对吧？他真是个绝佳的人，对吧？Jelly，他太棒了，真是个天才。
Talent and awesome guy. Great husband, great father, he's the awesome, what a talent. Talent and awesome guy. Great husband, great father, I mean, just present. Just all around. But to come in and hang out, that would be like a dream. That would be a total dream to be a fly on the wall with a bunch of you guys. It would be unbelievable. I mean, come any time.
既有天赋又是个极好的人。好丈夫，好父亲，我的意思是，他就坐在那里。全方位的好。但能加入进来一起玩，那简直就像个梦想。对于我们这群人来说，能当个墙角飞虫旁听一下，那绝对是个终极梦想。那太不可思议了。我的意思是，随时欢迎来。
The cool thing about it is we do it. Wow. I think it's what made, it's similar to what y'all do, it's what made Smart List the biggest podcast on the earth. We immediately heard three friends who were at the top of their class, but our buddies at core, just hanging out and being fucking buddies.
最酷的是我们确实这么做了。哇。我认为这正是造就——这和你们做的事很像——这也是让《Smart List》成为地球上最宏大播客的原因。我们立刻听到三个站在各自领域顶峰的朋友，但本质上还是我们的哥们，聚在一起胡扯、当该死的哥们。
Like, that's us. Like, when we're all sitting around together, passing a guitar, like, we're not a bunch of country music superstars, we're a bunch of dumbass songwriters trying to show that we can still write dumb ass songs. You know what I'm saying? Yeah, no, you're right.
就像我们一样。当我们坐在一起传着弹吉他时，我们不是什么乡村音乐超级巨星，我们只是一群笨蛋词曲作者，试图证明我们依然能写出好听的笨蛋歌。你知道我在说什么吗？是的，没错，你说得对。
Two buddies and Jason and we, you know, we do the show and that's... We got him everybody! We got him! How about this, this is probably as stupid as all the other questions I ever ask, but what about, I would imagine that your life before things got better was a richer pot from you to pull from to write songs versus now, are you, the question is, are you as inspired with stuff to write about now that things have the edges
两个哥们和杰森，我们呢，我们做这个节目，然后就是……我们把这家伙请到了！我们请到他了！话又说回来，这可能和我的其他所有愚蠢问题一样蠢，不过，我想你在生活好转之前的日子，为你写歌提供了更丰富的素材库，相比之下现在呢？问题是，既然你生活中的那些棱角已经被磨平了——这是你应得的——你现在写歌的灵感还像以前那样充沛吗？
a little bit more rounded in your life, deservedly so? Or are you still finding stuff that really grabs your heartstrings now? I pull from a little less personal pain, but I've gotten a thousand more muses. Okay, great. It kind of balanced itself out. I get, I'm not making this number up,
还是说你现在依然能找到真正触动你心弦的东西？我从个人痛苦中汲取的素材稍微少了一点，但我拥有了一千倍的缪斯。哦，太棒了。这算是自我平衡了。我收到——我可没有编造这个数字，
I'm sure y'all do too, but I get thousands of messages across every platform a day and 70% of them are like real, hey man, your song helps me out of a hole. I got sober to your music. I dealt with the death of my father with cancer to this song, like this song, like, we played this at my mother's funeral,
我敢说你们也是如此——我每天在各个平台上收到成千上万条信息，其中70%都是这样的：嘿，兄弟，你的歌帮我走出了低谷。我是听着你的音乐才戒酒成功的。我通过这首歌度过了父亲因癌症去世的悲痛，像这首歌，我们在我母亲的葬礼上播放了它，
we played this at my cousin who had a fentanyl overdose at his funeral, so like, it goes back to me being very empathic. Yeah, yeah. I feel this, like I'm the kind of guy that's like, if you start crying, I will cry. We will cry together, I have a nobody cries alone policy. You know Like I'm the kind of guy that's like, if you start crying, I will cry. We will cry together. I have a nobody cries alone policy.
我们在因芬太尼过量去世的表弟的葬礼上也播放了这首歌。所以，这要归功于我极具同理心。对，对。我能感同身受，我是那种只要你开始哭，我就会跟着哭的人。我们会一起哭，我有一个“没有人应该孤单哭泣”的政策。你知道吗？就像我是那种只要你开始哭，我就会跟着哭的人。我们会一起哭。我有一个“没有人应该孤单哭泣”的政策。
You know what I'm saying? It's just automatically. So it's like I hear these stories. I hear these stories every day. So I'm not, I had a, man, this is, I've never said it this way, but there was a moment I thought I was special because of where I was from and what I'd been through.
你知道我在说什么吗？这完全是自动的。所以我每天都会听到这些故事。我每天都在听这些故事。所以我不，我有过一个——天哪，我从来没有这样表达过——曾有一段时间，我以为自己很特别，因为我的出身和我的经历。
Like I thought like, oh, the world's clicking for me because all this shit I went through makes me special. And then I realized what makes me special is that we've all been through some sort of shit and that I am a representation of that. And once I realized that I wasn't telling my unique specialty story, I was telling the story of millions of American who have felt the same kind of pain
就像我曾想，哦，世界正在为我敞开大门，因为我经历过的那些烂事让我变得与众不同。后来我才意识到，真正让我与众不同的是，我们所有人都经历过某种操蛋的遭遇，而我正是这种经历的代言人。一旦我意识到我讲述的不是我独一无二的专属故事，而是在讲述数百万经历过同样痛苦的美国人的故事时，
and don't take this, Sean, to speak on it, but I speak for Sean's brother. Right. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Like I am an active voice for Sean's brother right now. Brother Sean knew that before it is called or not. Most of my life mission is getting people to understand that alcoholics and addicts are good people. They're not bad people,
肖恩，你别介意我这么说，但我就权当在为肖恩的兄弟发声。对。对，对，对，对。就像我现在是肖恩兄弟的积极发声者一样。不管肖恩的兄弟在生前是否意识到了这一点。我生命中的大部分使命，就是让人类明白：酗酒者和瘾君子其实是好人。他们并不是坏人，
they're just in the middle of a bad situation. That's exactly right. And it's one of the core tenets of recovery is that idea is that you're exactly right, you're not unique, it's that people can identify with that. Exactly. And it's through that identification that it creates community,
他们只是身处糟糕的困境中。完全正确。这也是戒瘾的核心原则之一，你的想法完全正确，你并不特殊，关键在于人们能够产生共鸣。确实如此。正是通过这种共鸣，它创造了社群，
and community is the opposite of addiction. When you can create that. Mm, that's it. It's so powerful. The opposite of addiction is connection, baby. You're know. I mean, it's so powerful. The opposite of addiction is connection, baby. You're speaking to me, Will, let's go. That's it, man. It's so true. It's so true.
而社群正是成瘾的对立面。当你能建立起这种联系时。嗯，就是这样。这太有力量了。成瘾的对立面是连接，宝贝。你知道的。我的意思是，这太有力量了。成瘾的对立面是连接，宝贝。你这话说到我心坎里去了，威尔，我们上吧。就是这样，伙计。太对了。太对了。
And then when you do that, when you go through that and everything that you've been through and everything you just said, Mr. Roll, is that you are now, like I said, at the beginning of this interview, you are now a light and you speak so eloquently about everything you've been through and the kind of enlightenment that you've gone through and it's such a,
然后当你经历这一切，经历你所经历过的一切以及你刚才所说的所有事情时，罗尔先生，正如我在这次采访开始时所说的那样，你现在就像一盏明灯，你如此雄辩地谈论着你所经历的一切，以及你所经历的那种精神启迪，这真的像是一个——
like people are now drawn to you for those reasons and people seek out your advice, your guidance. It's really fascinating. And they're uplifted through that connection. Yeah. and people seek out your advice, your guidance. It's really fascinating. And they're uplifted through that connection. Yeah. The message is different when it, a message always hits different
就像人们现在因为这些原因而被你吸引，人们会寻求你的建议、你的指导。这真的很迷人。他们通过这种连接得到了升华。对。人们会寻求你的建议、你的指导。这真的很迷人。他们通过这种连接得到了升华。对。当一个信息来自于同路人时，
when it comes from one of its own. Yeah. You know what I mean? Like that's why I go back to jails and that's why I go to rehabs because I remember none of our own ever came back and talked to us. So no matter how well intentioned other people were,
它的传达效果总是截然不同的。对。你知道我的意思吗？这就是为什么我重返监狱，为什么我去戒毒所的原因，因为我记得我们当中从来没有人回来和我们谈过心。所以无论其他人怀有多么善良的意图，
it just didn't hit, you know what I mean? Because it wasn't coming from a place that we could like. And it lights you up as much as music lights you up. The messaging, yeah, I love that. I love that. Yes, baby, it's my real purpose, man, is to serve. Giving it away is the best feeling of all, right? I mean, that's where the power comes from.
就是没有那种感觉，你知道我的意思吗？因为它不是出自我们喜欢的那种地方。而且它点燃你的程度，就像音乐点燃你一样。这种传达的信息，对，我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个。是的，宝贝，我真正的目标，伙计，就是去奉献。把它送出去是最好的感觉，对吧？我的意思是，力量就是从这里来的。
That's the hack that people don't really. You need a blessing, be a blessing, baby. You need a blessing, be a blessing, baby. You need a blessing, be a blessing. Well, it's like, you know, if you're feeling unloved it's because you're not being loving. That's been my experience. And if I push love out on people, I get that back on me tenfold.
这就是人们不太了解的小窍门。你需要祝福，那就去成为别人的祝福，宝贝。你需要祝福，那就去成为别人的祝福，宝贝。你需要祝福，那就去成为别人的祝福。嗯，这就好像，你知道的，如果你感到没有人在乎，那是因为你没有去关心别人。这是我的经验。如果我把爱传递给别人，我会得到十倍的回报。
And that's the hack. Yeah, that's what I was trying to say. It's 100% true. If you're, and this is a hack that I, that I'm a little reluctant to share. This is% true. If you're, and this is a hack that I, that I'm a little reluctant to share, this is totally true. That I find if I'm feeling low, or if I'm feeling like unconnected,
这就是诀窍。是的，我刚才就是想说这个。百分之百是真的。如果你，而且这是一个我，我有点不太愿意分享的诀窍。这是百分之百真的。如果你，而且这是一个我，我有点不太愿意分享的诀窍，这完全是真的。我发现如果我感到失落，或者如果我感到孤立无援，
or I'm feeling lonely, or whatever, I reach out to somebody else and ask them how they're doing. It's the most unbelievable, you know, and you can- I'm gonna send you my number in the chat. Just at the bottom of the screen. We know how you're doing. You're at home in your thing. Like, and Sean, I know it.
或者我觉得孤独，或者别的什么，我会主动联系别人，问问他们过得怎么样。这真是难以置信，你知道的，你可以在——我要在聊天里把我的号发给你。就在屏幕底部。我们知道你过得怎么样。你待在家里做你自己的事。就像，肖恩，我很清楚。
You're at home having no experience. You know, it's a sad Hollywood story. They can't even do a real life Hollywood story because there's not enough info. There's not enough life. They can't fill an hour because it's too boring. It's got famous and rich and sad in his house. Who's going to watch that?
你待在家里毫无生活体验。你知道，这是一个悲伤的好莱坞故事。他们甚至无法拍出一个真实的好莱坞故事，因为信息根本不够。生活阅历不够。他们凑不够一个小时，因为太无聊了。变得富有、有名却在家里感到悲伤。谁会看那种东西？
A webisode. We could do a webisode. We might be able to do a webisode. We'll go back, Jason. We'll produce it for Dum Dum. Look it. Scotty got me this pencil holder. It's a little typewriter.
一个网络短剧。我们可以拍个网络短剧。我们也许能拍个网络短剧。我们会回去的，杰森。我们会为“笨蛋”制作它的。你看。斯科蒂给我买了这个笔筒。是个小打字机。
There we go. I'm excited about that. That took up a week. That was a week. That was a week of shit, just to get that. Jelly Roll Man, honestly having you here has been so amazing. This is awesome. Yeah, you're just such an inspiration
好了，这就对了。我对此很兴奋。这花了一个星期。那是一个星期。那是糟心的一周，就为了搞定这个。果冻卷（Jelly Roll），老实说，你能来这里真是太棒了。这太棒了。是的，你简直是一个巨大的灵感源泉
and thank goodness that you are who you are, man. You've touched a lot of people. You certainly touched me and I know you've helped a lot of people. So thank you for your kindness and your voice and everything and your music and your artistry, all of it, dude. Well, thanks for inviting me on.
谢天谢地，你就是你，伙计。你感动了很多人。你当然也感动了我，我知道你帮过很多人。所以谢谢你的善良、你的声音以及一切，还有你的音乐、你的艺术才华，全都是，老朋友。嗯，谢谢你邀请我来。
Jason, thanks for mistaking me for Kitty Chesney, who's a foot shorter and 300 pounds lighter. And Sean, I love you to absolute death, man. I love all of y'all. I can't thank y'all enough for what y'all are doing for the world, man. How happy y'all are making people, how much joy you're bringing to people's car
杰森，谢谢你把我误认成基蒂·切斯尼（Kitty Chesney），他比我矮一英尺，轻了300磅。还有肖恩，我爱你爱到骨子里了，伙计。我爱你们所有人。我真是感激不尽，谢谢你们为世界所做的一切，伙计。你们让人们多么快乐，你们给人们的汽车带去了多少欢乐
every day. It's, man, I just hope y'all know that this was, I'm sure y'all did it just to, you know, just to connect with each other and it just kind of spread, but man, that's, you are helping so many people, man. You are a direct servant, man. You don't even, I'm sure you know it. I'm acting like y'all don't know, but you're many people, man. You are a direct servant, man. You don't even, I'm sure you know it. I'm acting like y'all don't know,
每一天。这，伙计，我只是希望你们知道，这，我确信你们这么做，你知道的，只是为了和彼此建立联系，然后它就传开了，但是伙计，那是，你们正在帮助这么多人，伙计。你们是真正的服务者，伙计。你们甚至不——我确信你们知道。我表现得好像你们不知道一样，但你们有很多人，伙计。你们是真正的服务者，伙计。你们甚至不——我确信你们知道。我表现得好像你们不知道一样，
but you're serving people, dog. You're not wasting an hour or two of your life every day just shooting the shit with your friends, man. You're helping a lot. My therapist listens to y'all. He's never been excited about me doing anything, but this was like a really big deal. This and Jay Shetty for him were like, whoa, I can't believe.
但你在为人们服务，老兄。你每天不是浪费一两个小时的生命和朋友瞎扯淡，伙计。你帮了大忙。我的治疗师经常听你们的节目。他从来没有对我的任何成就感到激动过，但这真的算是一件大事。对他来说，这次节目和杰·谢蒂（Jay Shetty）的节目简直就像是，哇，我真不敢相信。
I'm sure you're as thankful as we are that people are actually listening to what it is we wanna say, right? And it's a real joy. It's a blessing. Y'all lead with love, baby. Y'all lead with love. Thanks, bro.
我确信你和我们一样庆幸，人们真的在倾听我们想说的话，对吧？这真是一种快乐。这是一种祝福。你们以爱引领，宝贝。你们以爱引领。谢谢，兄弟。
And if you're ever in LA, please let's have a meal or something. I would love that. Please, we'll do it. Yeah, we'll live for sure. Well, I'll reach out. I'd love to see y'all again sometime, man. Love to have you.
如果你什么时候来洛杉矶，请务必一起吃个饭什么的。我很乐意。拜托，我们一定会的。是的，我们肯定会聚的。嗯，我会联系你的。什么时候有机会真想再见到你们，伙计。很乐意接待你。
Yeah. Thank you, the great Jellie Roll, thank you brother. Thanks for being with us. What a nice man, that's a nice way to start the day. I didn't get a chance to talk to him at our event. I mean, just said hello. But I was struck as you were, just how infectious his light, his energy was, his warmth,
好的。谢谢你，伟大的果冻卷，谢谢你，兄弟。谢谢你和我们在一起。多好的人啊，这是开始新的一天的好方式。我在我们的活动上没机会跟他说话。我是说，只是打了个招呼。但我跟你一样被打动了，他的光芒、他的能量是多么富有感染力，他的热情，
when he shook our hands. It was kind of took me back. He's the kind of guy you want to hang out with. You want in your life, it'll make your life better. Those kinds of people make your life better. He makes, he's, there's a guy, again, like he's just, when he's turned his life around and he's spent, he's dedicated his life
当我们握手时。这有点让我回过神来。他是那种你想跟他厮混的人。你想把他留在你的生命里，这会让你的生活变得更好。那种人会让你的生活变得更好。他让，他，又是一个这样的人，就像他，当他扭转了自己的人生，他把时间，他奉献了自己的生命
to making other people's lives better, which is fucking awesome. Yeah, I love it. You know, that option is available to you, Will. Yeah. Listen, I'm out there with the one. You can start today. I'm trying.
去让别人的生活变得更好，这他妈太棒了。是的，我喜欢这样。你知道，这种选择对你也是开放的，威尔。是的。听着，我不是那种人。你可以从今天开始。我在努力。
I mean, I'm not the one, again, I can't, you guys have nothing to talk, what are you talking about on a talk show? It just occurred to me, there's nothing. What are you talking about? Oh, I come up with bits. Yeah. You know, I come up with bits, you know, funny stories.
我的意思是，我不是那种人，再说一次，我不能，你们有什么好聊的，你们在访谈节目里到底聊些什么？我突然想到，根本没有。你们在聊什么？哦，我想段子。对。你知道的，我想段子，你知道，有趣的故事。
I come up with bits. you know, funny stories. I come up with bits. I tell garbage about how I don't like to walk around hotel rooms with my bare feet and crap like that. I just make it up. Oh my God. But we know them all. How much you run out of them?
我想段子。你知道，有趣的故事。我想段子。我胡说八道说我怎么不喜欢光脚在酒店房间里走来走去之类的破事。我都是瞎编的。噢，天哪。但我们全都知道了。你难道不会用完吗？
Oh yeah, I do need some new stories. I know. I know. Will, you're always like, you got to go see the world so you have something to talk about. It's true. Well, just not even just on talks. You're just in general read books meet people. I do get off my fucking back No I'm gonna get off your fucking back I was put on this planet to be on your back egging you on to I want you to be a better
哦，是的，我确实需要一些新故事。我知道。我知道。威尔，你总是说，你得去看看世界，这样你才有话题可聊。确实。嗯，甚至不仅仅是在访谈节目里。你只是通常应该读读书、见见人。行了，别他妈烦我了。不，我偏要烦你。我来到这个星球就是为了烦你，催促你，我希望你成为一个更好的人
I love Sean Hayes. Yeah, I want the best for him. Okay? Very nice. Why don't you just turn on CNN International and you can see it. No, you're not. You're at home. Or watch a movie with whatever landmark you want to see. It's about getting into the world, you know. It's so cool.
我爱肖恩·海斯（Sean Hayes）。是的，我希望他一切都好。好吗？太好了。你怎么不干脆打开CNN国际频道看看呢。不，你不会的。你待在家里。或者随便看一部你想看的地标建筑电影。这全在于融入世界，你知道的。这太酷了。
What about my sheets and my pillow? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Or Sean, you should get to what you're looking at on your screen. Go ahead. What was your thought? Oh no. I'm looking, I can't find one. Are you trying to think of, well, you know,
那我床单和枕头怎么办？对，对，对。或者肖恩，你应该看看你屏幕上看到的东西。说吧。你刚才在想什么？哦，没有。我在找，我找不到一个。你在试着想，嗯，你知道，
if you could travel a lot back and forth to Los Angeles and New York, if you had to. Well, we've done that. We've used that one so many times. Bye. What about this, but I don't want to travel anywhere because I'd miss you guys, because if I leave somewhere, I'd have to wave. Good.
如果你能经常往返于洛杉矶和纽约，如果非得去的话。好吧，我们已经做过了。那个梗我们用过太多次了。再见。这个怎么样，但我不想去任何地方旅行，因为我会想念你们，因为如果我离开某个地方，我就得挥手。再见。
Good. Bye. I feel like we've done that too. That's right. We never come up with anything where bye is in the middle of a word. Okay, wind by our nose, Psalm go by, two by two, selling by him.
再见。再见。我觉得我们连这个也做过了。没错。我们从来没想过“再见”藏在词语中间的情况。好吧，耳边的清风，诗歌流逝，成双成对，向他推销。
Hey, listen, listen, listen. A house by the lake. Listen, the good news is you can go anywhere in the world, right, and you can do stuff. And if something happens back home, if somebody gets hurt, somebody gets killed, and the cops interview you, if you're out of town, you've got a great alibi.
嘿，听着，听着，听着。湖边的房子。听着，好消息是你可以去世界的任何地方，对吧，你可以做各种事情。如果在家里发生了什么事，如果有人受伤了，有人被杀了，而警察找你盘问，如果你正好不在城里，你就有一个完美的不在场证明。
Bye. Bye. Oh, that's good. Bye. Yeah, that's fantastic. Well. Eh, eh, eh, eh. Smart. Nice. That fence passed me well. SmartLess
再见。再见。哦，那太棒了。再见。是的，太棒了。好吧。呃，呃，呃，呃。聪明。不错。那栅栏对我很有用。SmartLess
SmartLess SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf. by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armgerf. Smart. Less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
SmartLess节目由贝内特·巴尔比科（Bennett Barbico）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）和罗布·阿尔姆杰夫（Rob Armjarf）100%有机手工制作。由贝内特·巴尔比科（Bennett Barbico）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）和罗布·阿尔姆杰夫（Rob Armgerf）制作。Smart Less. 本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。